- We live, baby!
Everybody, shut up!
We're making art!
- You enjoy this content right now!
- Is that what you say
before you start recording?
Content, content!
- I shouldn't even
notice what you're doing.
It's so weak.
We're in a new studio.
You can shout, Garnt.
- Can you give us an example of that?
(Connor yells)
(chill music plays)
- Hello, gamers.
Welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
I am boy with boys.
You guys know us by now.
And we have a themed
episode, as you can tell.
- We've never done this-
- We've never done this before.
- Like, imagine this,
what if we make a three by three, guys?
Never done that before, before.
- Have you heard of an episode
that will not go on a tangent?
I'm just kidding.
We will go on tangents.
- Well, I think 'cause we're,
me and Garnt are planning to
go out to the UK for a bit,
so we need to record a little
more episodes in advance.
So, our solution to do
that is themed episodes,
so that we don't run out
of stuff to talk about.
- Yeah, we don't want to run
out of stuff to talk about.
- I like the three by three episodes
'cause it's just a good
excuse to talk about shit
that maybe we're not gonna
ever tangent towards.
- It's also just hilarious
that we kind of brought back
the three by three, like...
- I didn't even know that was a thing.
- Yeah, right.
People haven't done it since like 2010.
But anyway, we've done a couple
of three by three episodes
in the past.
We did one on anime.
We've done one on games,
and I think this will
be the third one now.
We're gonna talk about movies!
Not anime movies though.
- Actual live action movies
with real people.
- [Joey] With real people.
- Because I feel like we don't-
- I like how we have to fucking specify
we watch real movies.
- Yeah, of course because
to some people it's like,
"Oh, so nine Ghibli films?
"Is that gonna be-"
- Honestly like I don't get
to talk about live action movies a lot,
even though I feel like
I've watched a hell of a lot
of live action movies.
But the biggest problem I had
when making this three by
three was I don't remember
what the fuck I've watched.
- Well, we've been watching
movies God knows how long,
right?
- For like my entire life.
- There's no like my movie list either.
- Yeah, I feel like when you
got into anime specifically,
it was probably at a point
where you really like cared
about it a lot, you know what I mean?
So, you made note of what you're watching.
You've been watching movies
your whole God damn life
'cause it's just what you do.
- Well, didn't you go through
like the IMDb top 200?
- I went through it to remind myself,
"All right, what have I seen?
"Okay, I know.
"I like that, that one's good."
- I literally had to go down that list
to remind myself of what I've seen.
- Okay, so what, like,
what logic did you guys use to
choose your three by threes?
- Okay, so in my head,
I always have like a
top three movies ready.
'Cause, you know, you're
always gonna be asked,
"Hey, what's your favorite movies?"
I always have like a top three,
but three by three you need nine movies.
So I'm like, all right, shit.
All right, I'll fill in the
rest of the six with like movies
that I thought were really good
that I want to recommend to people
or movies that I know
I've seen multiple times
and I'll keep watching multiple times.
- Mine were not recommendations at all.
I was thinking maybe
I'll just make the ones
where like the movies
I really, really like.
And then I just like,
I just went through like my
list of movies I really liked,
and I just like too many fucking movies.
I literally could not narrow it down.
It needs to be like a fucking top 50 list.
- I've seen most of the IMDb top 200.
I was like, this is not healthy.
- It would literally just
be like the IMDb top 200
most of the time.
So like, I just went, fuck that.
What are the movies that
I've just seen the most?
And like, if it's on TV, I'm just like,
"I got time to watch this movie."
- I don't know.
I just picked movies that
made me think of something.
Feel, feel things.
I don't know.
- Raw emotions.
- A movie that gave me an experience.
- Yeah, I mean, I feel that's-
- 'Cause yeah, I feel like the
problem with that for me is
that too many movies do
that for me, so it's like-
- You're out here like fucking having
an emotional breakdown
every movie you watch?
- I like movies.
I like movies.
- It's really hard also to
like get rid of recency bias
as well.
'Cause like immediately I thought
of like the last 10 movies I watched,
and I'm like, "Were they as
memorable as these other movies
"that I probably haven't
seen in like five, 10 years?"
- I'm gonna say there's
some movies on my list
that I haven't seen in fucking years,
and I've put them on just because-
- I can't wait to quiz you about movies
that you haven't watched in years.
- I was like obsessed with them as a kid.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So some of those are on my list, so.
- What, do you got the
fucking Teletubbies movies?
(everyone laughs)
How far back we talking here, Garnt?
- Pretty far back.
You'll see, you'll see.
- So, let's see if our movie tastes are
as pretentious as our anime tastes.
But we're gonna decide
as always with Trash Box
to see who goes first.
Oh, get that out of here.
- Is that still in there from last time?
- That's in there from last time.
Throw that out.
- That was a scripted joke last time,
and we just forgot we
put her in this time.
- We forgot this time around.
That was a genuine bit.
All right, who wants
to pick who goes first?
- All right, I'll go first.
- I hope it's not me.
I really don't want to go first.
Oh, thank God, it's Garnt.
Thank God, it's Garnt.
- Oh, fuck, I didn't want to go first.
- Bring up Garnt's three by three.
- Okay.
- [Joey] So, you're logic
for your three by three was-
(Connor laughs)
Oh my God.
- This is why I didn't want to go first
because I've got to
fucking defend this shit.
- Okay, there are some
there where I'm like,
"Okay, okay.
"Genuinely good movies."
And then there's a...
- Okay, so this is split into two parts.
- I just love how "Space Jam"
is in the fucking middle.
(Garnt laughs)
It's like the fucking epicenter.
- This is my movie!
- As a fucking kid,
like as a kid who grew up in the 90s,
everyone went through a
fucking "Space Jam" phase.
This is a classic.
It's a fucking classic.
I mean, as a kid, I didn't
watch the fucking NBA,
didn't even watch the
fucking "Looney Tunes."
And even as a kid,
I fucking watched this so many times,
every time it was on TV,
I rewatched this shit so much.
"Space Jam" is amazing.
- It's a good movie.
- You sound like a kid trying to justify
why you shit on the bed.
(everyone laughs)
Like to your parents.
- Do you want to go through your list?
- All right, so, okay.
So, "Kung Fu Hustle."
- [Connor] That's good.
- [Joey] That's a good movie.
- [Connor] That's a great movie.
- [Garnt] "Rush Hour 2."
(everyone laughs)
- [Connor] Yo, I fucking
love "Rush Hour 2!"
- [Joey] Yeah, okay.
- [Garnt] "Memento."
"Scott Pilgrim vs. the World."
- I had a feeling you were
going to put "Memento" for some,
I don't know why.
- Yeah, I don't know why,
'cause I was that close to
putting "Memento" on my list,
but I'm like, "I feel Garnt's
gonna put 'Memento' on."
I don't know why.
- [Garnt] "Space jam."
- [Joey] Of course.
- [Garnt] "The Matrix."
- [Joey] First "Matrix," right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, the first "Matrix."
"The 40-Year-Old Virgin."
(everyone laughs)
"Snatch," and "Confessions."
So, this is very much split up
into my childhood obsession movies
and then some movies that
I just want people to watch
and recommend them.
That's why I've just
watched it so many times.
- Okay, so before, we, I guess,
which movies have you seen, Joey, here?
- I've seen all of them
except for "Kung Fu Hustle"
and "Confessions."
- I've not seen,
"Snatch" sounds so familiar.
- Is "Snatch" the one where-
- That's the one where he
fucking is like a boxer, right?
- Yeah.
"Snatch" is a Guy Ritchie movie.
- It's a good movie.
- I think it's Guy Ritchie's
best movie like by far.
It's that and "Lock, Stock."
And I was thinking
about putting a Quentin
Tarantino movie on, but-
- I'm surprised there is
no Quentin Tarantino movie.
- Okay, I had a feeling someone
else was gonna put it on.
So, that's why I put on "Snatch"
instead of Quentin Tarantino
because it's like,
"Snatch" and like "Reservoir Dogs"
which is like my Quentin
Tarantino movie of choice,
it's kind of like, it's the
same kind of feel for me.
And I feel like more people
know about Quentin Tarantino,
which is why I wanted to put "Snatch"
which is kind of like,
if you want kind of a
British Quentin Tarantino
kind of movie where it's
just got amazing dialogue.
And I love the concept of a
lot of different characters
that has nothing to do with each other
just kind of like merging
into one coherent storyline.
And there's just bants.
The banter in this is so fucking good
that I still quote this to this day.
Like, so many of the
lines I "come up with"
just comes from "Snatch."
(everyone laughs)
It's just got great writing,
great fucking humor.
- Wow, Gigguk literally
stealing from "Snatch"
- I haven't seen "Confessions."
- Oh, me neither.
I've never even heard of it.
- "Confessions" is
actually a Japanese movie.
(Joey gasps)
- Very fitting.
- I know, and it's the one movie-
- Oh, Kokuhaku.
I think I've read the book.
I read the book, yes, okay.
- I didn't know it was
even based on a book.
But it's probably my favorite
revenge movie of all time.
- I think it's a Miyabe Miyuki book.
Is it the one where it's
like set in high school?
- Yeah.
- With like two girls?
- Kind of.
- I think that's the one.
- So, the concept of this movie is
the main character is a teacher.
And she used to teach, teach a class.
And so these two students
from these class,
or I think it was like
two or three students
from this class,
they basically murder her daughter.
But because of Japanese
laws, if you're like a minor,
then you can't be charged
even if you've technically
like killed somebody.
- Which is fucked.
- Yeah, yeah, which is fucked,
and that's like the whole
premise of this movie.
And the premise of this movie is
just her basically
playing fucking 5D chess
against these high schoolers,
and just coming up with a very
unique like revenge scheme
against these kids.
And it's kinda like maybe
similar to "Old Boy"
if you've seen "Old Boy," but maybe just-
- Yeah, I've seen "Old Boy."
- Maybe just not as fucked.
I think...
- "Old Boy" is pretty fucked.
- "Old Boy" is pretty
fucked, and my problem
with "Old Boy" is that-
- I'm surprised "Old Boy"
isn't on your three by three.
- Well, my problem with "Old
Boy" is I really liked it,
but there are definitely
some parts of "Old Boy"
that really push your
suspension of disbelief.
Like, without spoiling,
like without spoiling the ending
of "Old Boy" or something,
there's some plot elements
where you're just like-
- Like the final twist?
- Yeah, like the final
twist where you're just-
- You've seen it?
- Yeah.
- The final twist where
you're just like, "I guess..."
(everyone laughs)
"Can the human mind be
tricked into doing this?
"That's like kind of pushing it."
What I like about
"Confessions" is that it's
kind of like the same kind of deal
where it's one person
getting revenge over people,
but it's just, it's kinda like,
she's kinda like a Light
Yagami kind of character
where it's a very, it's a
very intricate revenge plot-
- But it's believable.
- But it's believable, and it's,
I mean, it's believable
because the whole premise
is fucked to begin with.
Because this is real,
like, you know, Japanese
minors cannot be charged
even if they kill somebody,
and that's like the premise of the movie.
But the way it unravels is
really, really interesting.
And for a Japanese movie as well,
one of the biggest things I remember
when watching this movie
for the first time is
that out of nowhere they
start playing Radiohead.
- Hell yeah!
- I'm just like,
"Is that fucking Radiohead
I'm listening to now?"
And so Radiohead is-
- Instant 10 out of 10.
(everyone laughs)
- And so like literally one of
the best parts of this movie,
it was just like, you know,
like the song for like the epic reveal
where she reveals everything,
it's just fucking Radiohead.
And I'm just like,
"This is the best reveal
I've ever seen in a movie."
- Which Radiohead song is it?
- I can't remember.
- Just remember the emotions.
- I just remember the emotions.
But it's not the most
famous Radiohead song.
Yeah, it's the one movie
that I think is like really underground
'cause it's a Japanese movie.
And everyone who's
watched it so far has been
really, really fucking impressed.
And I don't see many people
talking about this movie
'cause I feel like
Japanese cinema in general
just gets looked over a lot, but-
- I feel like 'cause they
tackle very Japanese things
more often than not.
Like, the way they go about
things is very Japanese
and like kind of like doesn't really make,
not that it doesn't make
sense, but just kind of odd.
- Yeah, there's a lot of like
cultural elements and things
that they throw back to that
where other people will be like,
"Oh, that doesn't happen in my school."
- Yeah, you have to kind of like
just look past a lot of things I think
when you watch Japanese
movies as foreigners.
You can't relate to most of the stuff.
- Yeah, 'cause like I've
definitely read this book before
and I really, really enjoyed it,
like back in like high school as well.
I think this is quite an old book.
But yeah, I mean, for one,
I didn't even know that this
was like a movie, first of all.
I didn't even know it
was available in English.
'Cause like a lot of Japanese
cinema doesn't make it
outside of Japan.
- There's always just translations online.
- Oh yeah, of course.
But it's like, I don't know.
I just wasn't expecting this.
- Yeah, like I recommend a lot
of movies from this director.
I can't remember his name,
but "Confessions" is my favorite one.
- Is it on the poster?
- "Memories of Matsuko" is another movie
that this director made that
is like really underground
even for like Japanese cinema,
but it's fucking amazing.
But yeah, just like if
you're gonna take anything
out of my three by three,
watch "Confessions"
because more people need to
know about "Confessions."
Kokuhaku.
It's an amazing movie.
It's one of the few Japanese movies
that I think is just easily
accessible to like anyone.
You don't really need to
know about Japanese culture.
It's just a good revenge plot.
And if you like "Old Boy" or, you know,
a lot of Korean movies,
you're probably gonna like "Confessions."
- Yeah, Miyabe Miyuki I
think is the original woman
who wrote Kokuhaku.
Like, all of her books kind of like deal
with this kind of like,
it's kind of like criticizing
fucked up parts of Japan
and like using it as like an advantage.
- [Connor] I'm down for that.
- It's really good, the book-
- [Connor] That sounds really good.
- Yeah.
- Might actually watch it.
The best movie on there is
"The 40-Year-Old Virgin."
- [Joey] Yeah, absolutely.
(everyone laughs)
- Honestly, I think...
'Cause I wanted to put a comedy movie on,
I was thinking what comedy
movie can I infinitely rewatch?
- You've got like three on there.
- [Joey] You've got "Scott
Pilgrim vs. the World."
"Space Jam," "Rush Hour 2."
- [Garnt] Is that a comedy?
- [Connor] "Scott Pilgrim" is a comedy.
- "Scott Pilgrim" is a comedy.
- Are you kidding me?
(Garnt sighs)
- I guess it's like a-
- It's a fucking comedy.
- It's a comedy!
- It's nonstop jokes.
- I mean, it's, okay, okay.
- It is the best with visual comedy.
- Yeah, okay, it is definitely
a, it's a comedy movie,
but it's not just got a comedy
in it because I love, I mean-
- Neither is "40-Year-Old Virgin."
It's quite a story of a man
coming to lose his virginity.
- Of course, it's a great
coming of age story.
- Yeah, coming of 40-year-old age.
- And I was thinking like what,
'cause I feel like
recently comedy movies have
kind of just died.
I don't know if that's the thing.
What's, what's...
- Well, I mean, you know, it's like,
there's like the fucking
Will Ferrell movies
and modern Adam Sandler films,
outside of "Uncut Gems,"
have just fucking made it go to,
I mean, it's literally only it.
But also the Adam Sandler
movies do extremely well
on Netflix.
- Oh, really?
- They're some of the most
watched things on Netflix.
The ones that they bought off-
- I don't think I've seen
an Adam Sandler movie since-
- 'Cause they're all so
mediocre, his new ones.
And the only one that he was amazing in
which was, "Uncut Gems" is
absolutely fucking amazing.
It wasn't even his movie.
He was just, he's the main actor.
- I've heard.
Is that a comedy movie
or is that just a movie?
- No, no, it's a pretty brutal movie.
Really fucking good though.
- All I've seen from that
is the clip when he goes,
"Oh my God, I'm gonna cum!"
(everyone laughs)
- What?
- That's pretty much all
I've seen of that movie.
- I need to watch this movie now!
- What is going on?
Adam Sandler, what is happening right now?
- Honestly it's a fucking amazing movie.
- I need to watch this movie.
- It's so fucking good.
"Uncut Gems," please
watch it if you haven't.
I think it's his best role.
- Yeah.
But yeah, "40-Year-Old Virgin" is like
to me the infinitely
rewatchable comedy movie for me.
- That used to play on British television,
I think like once a fucking week.
- No, that's why I've
watched it so many times.
- Everyone in the UK has watched it
'cause it use to play
all the fucking time.
- This is also one of those movies
that never leaves the airplane.
Like, it's always playing.
- Exactly, exactly.
- Like, if you look up
movies on an airplane,
like "the old classics"
genre, it's always in there.
- There's so many famous
scenes in that movie,
like the fucking tit scene
where they talk about feeling a boob.
- "It's like a sandbag."
(everyone laughs)
- And the fucking waxing scene as well.
It's iconic, it's iconic.
And I feel like this gets
talked about less than maybe,
like at least when it first
came out, because the iconic-
- Was that one if his like most famous,
like was that one of the
roles that blew him up?
- This one was when I first
started to know Steve Carell
because I didn't know about him before
because I think before that,
the only thing I've seen him
in was like "Bruce Almighty."
But he had like one
iconic scene out of that.
- He wasn't the main character, yeah.
- He wasn't the main character.
I mean, it was Jim Carrey.
But I feel like this was his first movie
where I was just like,
"Damn, this guy's funny.
"This is a funny fucking movie."
But, I remember back when this came out,
the iconic comedy movie
when this first came out was "Superbad."
- Classic.
- It was like 2000s humor.
Like those movies were all the rage.
- Everyone was quoting "Superbad,"
and I was just like,
"I kind of think 'The
40-Year-Old Virgin' is funnier."
That was just (laughs)
that was just me back then.
- I thought "Superbad" was
funny for like two months.
- Nah, nah, when you were in high school,
"Superbad" is like the funniest shit.
It's like, you're just going to.
- When you've heard of like the,
you know, 1,000th McLovin'
joke, you're just like,
"All right, yeah, I get it.
"I get."
- It's kind of same with "Borat," right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I should've put "Borat" on mine.
(everyone laughs)
- Actually, it's so funny.
Like, Sydney had never
seen "Borat" before.
So, she watched "Borat"
for the first time in 2021
about like a month ago.
And like, me, someone who's
like been quoting "Borat"
throughout my entire high school,
it's been quoted to death.
It's hard to find it funny anymore
because it's just been
like, everyone's just-
- It's so ingrained.
- It's so ingrained that I just cease
to find it funny anymore.
She still found it fucking hilarious.
- It's so funny.
It is legitimately hilarious.
- It is really funny, yeah.
- Like, when I watched that
movie, all I think is like,
"God damn, he's such a
fucking amazing actor."
There's no movie that
even comes close to like
that kind of experience,
like, of what he does.
It's crazy.
- Admittedly, you know,
like I can probably
quote most of that movie,
but I'd be lying if I said
every time I heard Borat go,
"My wife," like, I'm like,
that's just hilarious.
(everyone laughs)
- 'Cause Borat said, "My wife,"
and Sydney just fucking lost it.
And I'm like, "Oh shit,
this was funny at a point.
"I forgot this was legitimately funny."
- The genius of fucking
"Borat" was that it made you,
on a service level you think that,
"Oh, this is just hee hee
funny movie," making fun of,
but it was really just a
really fucking intelligent way
of showing how racist America is.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And that's how good,
and the best part was is
that those people were the ones quoting it
after the movie came out.
But it's like a genius way of showing it
in a way that, like,
he made a, he showed, like, how,
like, I guess there was like
a racist problems in America
before it was like talked
about wildly today.
And still it was massively
marketed towards the audience
that often didn't even know
that that's what he was poking fun at.
It's genius.
- Well, that's what I
fucking loved about Ali G
back in the day.
- Oh my God, that's a name
I haven't heard in so long.
- He has a movie as well.
- Oh my God, like the
first time I watched that,
like, I thought everything was scripted.
And like a lot of it is,
but like some of the interview
scenes and stuff like that,
like it's all non-scripted.
I'm like, how the fuck does he do that?
- He's just a genius at like
being able to turn a situation
and like make them look
stupid without having
to like make them think that
he's playing a character.
He's so good at that.
- Like, he is actually
like a social genius.
He knows how to work people so well.
And the thing is like,
he gets so invested in this character.
It's actually insane.
- It must be a nightmare
being married to him.
(everyone laughs)
- "Which character are
you tonight, honey?"
(everyone laughs)
- Like, 'cause I remember
like re-watching "Borat"
with Sydney, there was this
one scene where he gets drunk
with a bunch of American frat boys.
And at first I was like,
"There's no way this is real.
"This must be scripted."
And so we looked into it,
and it's totally real to the point-
- He got drunk with them.
- Yeah, to the point where
he got like blackout drunk
with them and just was able to stay
in character this entire fucking time.
- That's fucking dedication, man.
It's insane.
- So, I think by the time he
goes to do these characters,
it's so fucking baked in his
head that he's this character
that he doesn't even think,
"Oh, I'm doing an act."
- That's just him.
- He just thinks this
is me which is insane.
I don't know.
It's such an insane-
- Maybe you should have
put "Borat" on yours.
- I didn't put "Borat" on mine.
I wish I did though.
Just like the whole, I just
find it all so fascinating.
And like "What is America"
is so fucking funny as well.
Like, oh, he's just so funny.
- [Joey] Yeah, he's very, very good.
- Absolute fucking genius.
- Yeah.
So aside from that, I guess,
what else haven't you seen Joey?
- I've seen everything, oh,
"Kung Fu Hustle" I haven't seen.
- "Kung Fu Hustle,"
fucking, that's, that's-
- [Joey] It's a good movie?
- That's a fucking banger.
- I mean, it looks
fucking awesome already.
- To me it's like one of the
closest you could possibly get
to real life anime.
It's somehow wacky.
It's a wacky live action
kind of slapstick.
- Well, what it does is that it does,
to parody martial arts movies,
it just makes a martial arts
movie that is just an anime.
All the characters are
like, "I have this power."
And then they do like all
weird fucking spells and shit.
- Yeah, yeah.
So, like the premise
of this movie is like,
there's like this like ax
gang, this very famous gang,
and for some reason they invade this very,
very small village that nobody's heard of.
And it's just like this secret village
where coincidentally a lot
of martial arts masters have
just like all situated in this one city.
- I love it already.
- So, what happens is firstly,
they find three martial arts masters
who just happen to live in this city.
They didn't know they lived in this city.
Like, one person was just like,
I think like a barber or something or...
- It's been so long since I've watched it.
- It's been so long.
Yeah, but-
- [Ashley] The noodle store owner.
- Oh yeah, one was the noodle store guy.
- [Ashley] The tailor.
- Oh, the tailor, yeah, yeah.
- [Ashley] One was, like, the laborer.
- Damn, you remember the story.
You remember this better than me, Ashley.
- Were you in the movie?
- And so after they find out
these three martial arts
masters are in this village,
they were like, "Well,
we got to send assassins
"to assassinate them."
So, they send assassins
to like get rid of these
three martial arts masters.
And then it turns out that
there are even more, like,
higher up martial arts
masters just living in there.
- It's a pyramid.
- Hierarchy.
- Pyramid.
And so like they just find
out like more OP people
just keep fucking invading this village
and like more OP heroes
just keep coming out
of the woodworks.
It's fucking great.
- Oh yeah, it's just
literally just escalation.
- That sounds so good.
- It's such a fun movie.
- Why have I not heard of this movie?
- It's really, if you
watch martial arts movies-
- Which I used to.
- You'll know about this.
- That's the thing, during high school,
I had like a massive like spree
of just watching every Bruce
Lee and Jackie Chan movie
and like all the martial
arts movies I could think of.
- Same here.
- But I never heard of
this one for some reason.
- Yeah, I mean, I feel
like if you did go through
that martial arts phase,
this is like one of the peak of just,
it knows the genre so well that
it kind of parodies itself.
But at the same time
takes itself 100% serious.
It's just one of the best-
- I'd argue that's the best kind of movie.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly!
It does everything well
for a martial arts movie,
and that's why I love it.
It's got the wacky fights,
and it's got like the really
well choreographed fights
as well.
But speaking of martial arts fights
that defines my childhood,
"Rush Hour."
(everyone laughs)
- Speaking of Jackie Chan,
there he is right there.
- What can you say?
- I wish there was more "Rush Hour."
I need the dynamics.
- I really think that the "Rush
Hour" series was what got me
into the whole martial
arts genre to begin with.
(Garnt laughs)
- Yeah, I mean, honestly, maybe same.
I don't know.
It was so funny.
My friend showed me it when
I was like really young,
and I just fucking fell in love with it.
It was so fun.
- Yeah, I mean, it's like Jackie Chan
and Chris Tucker is a dynamic
that on paper should never work.
They should never have the
chemistry that they do,
but they have such good chemistry.
And the amount of times
I've rewatched "Rush Hour" one and two,
especially in my childhood,
was just like uncountable.
I actually don't know how
many times I've rewatched it
'cause it like defined like a good, like,
five-year period of my life
because that was what
started my martial arts phase
where I just watched so many
different martial arts movies,
it's 'cause of "Rush Hour."
- Jackie Chan is very, very funny.
- He's one of the most charismatic actors.
- I feel like in that that's
carried by Jackie Chan,
like how good he is at playing like dumb.
- Yeah.
- So good in this.
- Him playing off Chris
Tucker, it's just, it's just-
- Chris Tucker's just Chris Tucker.
And then Jackie Chan.
- He's just funny by himself.
And Jackie Chan is also
like funny by himself
for like a completely different reason.
It's like completely clash of styles.
But like I remember when I was doing,
doing, not the anime awards,
the Trash Taste awards.
When I was doing the "I
have a dream" speech.
People were just like,
"Wow, Garnt's really
parodying Martin Luther King
"really well."
And I'm just like, I actually
just took that speech
from "Rush Hour 2" when
Chris Tucker did it
at the casino scene.
- All of your fucking
jokes and everything come
from fucking movies.
- Everything you hear on
Gigguk is just movie quotes.
- I mean, this is the secret coming out.
When I'm just like, these
are the movies I've rewatched
so many times that they're
just ingrained in my mind.
- Was "Rush Hour 2" the best one?
- I think it was.
- What was the plot of "Rush
Hour 2," is that the Paris one?
- No, that was "Rush Hour 3."
That was, that (laughs)
"Rush Hour-"
- I love he just immediately knows this.
He's like, "Yeah, that's 'Rush Hour 3.'"
- I can't remember a
distinction between any of them.
They're all just one.
- All of the "Rush Hours"
kind of just blend together
for me.
- Yeah, I remember "Rush Hour
1" and "2" were the good ones.
- Was "3" bad?
I don't think "3" was bad.
- I think "3" was average.
- "3" was kind of like the contested one.
- I mean, Jackie Chan was
getting like a little bit old
when "Rush Hour 3" happened,
so like you could tell that he couldn't do
as many stunts as he could do.
"Rush Hour 1" and "2" I feel
like was Jackie Chan more,
like, he could get away with more things.
- He was in his prime.
- I don't feel it was his prime,
but it was definitely closer to his prime.
- The back end of his prime.
(everyone laughs)
- I think his prime was in like 1990.
- But yeah, I remember, I don't know why,
but I remember as a kid, I
slightly preferred "Rush Hour 2."
I think that was the
slightly better movie.
But I mean, "Rush Hour 1"
is still fucking brilliant
as well.
- [Joey] I mean, can we also
just talk about the fact
that I fully expected you to put "Memento"
in your three by three.
- Yeah, why?
Why?
- It just seems like-
- Have I ever talked about it?
- No, it just seems like a Garnt movie.
- I can picture the Gigguk video.
He's like, it's like,
"Guys, what if I told
you you could go back
"and get pictures or something?"
I just, I feel like I would
hear, I would hear like-
- How is that my Gigguk video?
- I feel like I can see you
making a video about "Memento"
even though you never,
it just feels like a Gigguk-
- Yeah, if I can imagine anyone
making a "Memento" video,
it's either you or John.
- I don't know why.
It just seems like the kind
of thing you would talk about.
- It's just like a very like artsy film.
I mean, it's a really good film.
- Is it an artsy film?
I don't think it's an artsy film.
- It's a bit artsy.
- It's like Christopher Nolan
being Christopher Nolan,
being like, "I have 500 IQ.
"Watch me try to present
my 500 IQ on film."
And it's just like, "Memento"
is one of the few, like,
films I think he's made that actually,
it was just like, "Oh,
Nolan, that was pretty smart.
"I gotta give you-"
- Well, "Memento" actually
was written by his brother.
- Okay.
- Yeah, it's based off
like a four page novella
written by Jonathan Nolan.
Christopher was like,
"You have four pages?
"Let me turn that into 400
and get Guy Pearce in it."
- Yeah, because I remember this
was one of his first movies
and they actually, I think this was,
I didn't know it was based on a novella
because I know that they made
a short film around this,
which I've actually seen,
and that's also really good,
and they expanded on this idea.
And it's just like Nolan with no budget.
Like, but still doing the
same kind of Nolan ideas.
Like, before he had a budget and-
- Like "Tenet."
- It's "Tenet" without a budget.
(everyone laughs)
- And then "Tenet" happens
and then he forgot that he
had to write like characters
and a plot, and just like (laughs)
to go along with the cool
ideas he had in his head.
But like, I feel like
this and "Inception,"
I mean, "Inception"
has been memed the fuck
to like hell and back.
But I remember the first
time I saw "Inception,"
I thought it was fucking amazing.
- Oh, of course, yeah.
- I mean, like I will
always give Nolan the chance
just because his peak-
- He always does something interesting.
- Like, he always, you know,
even if he doesn't make the best movie,
he always has interesting ideas
and he always tries something new,
which is what I can respect.
Not everything hits the
mark, but it's Nolan.
You can expect that he's not
gonna stay in his comfort zone.
- I mean, "Memento" is
definitely one of those movies
that like, well, A, you
have to watch more than once
to fully understand it,
but B, even after multiple watches,
it's like, "I don't get it."
- So to explain "Memento" to
anyone who hasn't seen it,
this is, yeah, it's gonna sound so weird,
but it's a movie that
plays in reverse kind of.
- Kind of.
- Yeah, because it's about this guy
who has a condition that gives
him short-term memory loss.
So, he can only remember
at most like five minutes at a time?
- [Joey] Something like that.
- Something like that.
- What a horrible existence.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's someone like that in
real life, I think actually.
- Yeah, I think so.
- Yeah, I mean, this is
an actual real condition
that exists.
- Love how they made it into a real thing.
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, you can't believe it.
- Oh my God, I can't believe
you have the same condition
as that guy from "Memento."
(everyone laughs)
But so because of this,
you're only presented like
five minutes of this movie
at a time.
And it's a movie that plays in reverse.
And it's about this guy
who has this condition
and is trying to get
revenge for the person
who murdered his wife,
which, you know, it's...
Combine a five minute memory,
a five minute short term memory
with a long-term revenge plot.
Things are...
- Things are about to get confusing.
- Things are gonna get confusing,
especially for the main character.
- Have I watched this movie?
- It's the one where, like,
every time he comes to again,
he looks at his body
because he tattoos all of
his memories onto his body.
- I think I've heard so
much about this movie
that I think I've seen it,
but I don't actually
think I've ever seen it.
- Oh, really?
- I don't think I have actually.
- It's very good.
- But I know the plot
and I know what happens.
- Yeah, yeah.
Everyone knows the plot to this movie.
- Everyone talks about it.
- You know what happens?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- So, you know the twist, right?
- I believe I do.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, we're not gonna say it.
- I don't wanna know
just in case I'm wrong.
But I think I know what the twist is.
- But like, I just remember the first time
I watched this movie and I'm just like,
"Damn, this is legit,
like, really clever."
500 IQ meme aside, you know,
you don't have to have a
high IQ to enjoy this movie.
- It's a very well-made movie
for such a confusing concept.
- Because at the beginning
you were just like,
how am I supposed to follow along
when the movie is playing in backwards?
How am I supposed to, like,
how is anything supposed
to be surprising to me?
And he finds a way to keep it interesting
throughout the entire run of the movie.
And then the ending kind of
just like slaps you in the face.
And you're like, "Oh.
"Oh shit, I did not
see that coming, okay."
And yeah.
And then this kind of launched his career,
and I feel like this is
one of his best works.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- Wow, thank you.
Thank you for that talk, Garnt.
- Welcome to my TED Talk.
Good evening.
It is I the GDawgAZ Anime Man.
So, the boys aren't with me right now,
but it's okay because I'm
going to channel their energy
to do this ad read.
(Garnt groans)
I love pizza crust!
Today's episode of
Trash Taste is sponsored
by Punishing Gray Raven.
As commander of the Gray Raven Unit,
you will be assembling an elite team
of cybernetically augmented soldiers,
leading them into intense
action combat missions
and unraveling the dark truths
behind the virus disasters.
And guys, you're in luck
'cause this is already out.
Yes, the first version
of Punishing Gray Raven Frozen
Darkness has been released
on August 3rd.
The new S attacking
character, Lucia Alpha,
one of the most powerful
characters in the game has
just been released this patch as well.
And guys, I gotta be honest.
The art style, the action battle,
and the gameplay is gonna surprise you.
Also, one of her old enemies, Rosetta,
is gonna be introduced
this update as well.
And the expert difficulty
levels bring you so much fun,
fierce action battles.
In the activity of Frozen Darkness,
you can unlock A-Class hero Kamui-Bastion
in our events by card exchanging for free.
Find out about his unique
skills of tackling the enemy.
So, if that sounds interesting to you,
then you can click the
link in the description
to give the game of go today.
Thank you very much to
Punishing Gray Raven
for sponsoring us today.
Back to the episode.
- I definitely need to
watch "Kung Fu Hustle"
and "Confessions."
- Yeah.
- Have you watched "Scott Pilgrim?"
- Of course, yeah.
- I liked "Scott Pilgrim."
- I really like "Scott Pilgrim."
- It's a good movie.
- I mean, it's a good movie?
It's a good movie?
- I think it's a really good movie.
- I mean, I'm a huge fan of Edgar Wright.
Edgar Wright's the other
director where I'm just like,
"Whatever you make,
I'll fucking watch it."
- Edgar Wright is like the
master of visual comedy
where like, he manages
to cut something in a way
or just like edit something in a way
that just makes it like,
"Whoa, I wasn't expecting that.
"But that's hilarious."
- Yeah, it's just, he's
one of the few people who,
whatever genre he takes on,
he'll put his own spin on the genre.
Like, it's so rare to find someone
who you can just watch a movie
and you can just tell it's Edgar Wright
through the editing itself
because it's such a-
- The snappiness of it.
- It's just like the unique and
the snappiness and the like-
- It's very rhythmic, isn't it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Is this your favorite Edgar Wright film?
- I think it is.
- I think mine is still
"Shaun of the Dead."
- I was debating putting
"Shaun of the Dead" on.
"Hot Fuzz," I like "Hot Fuzz."
- That's a great movie, yeah.
- "Hot Fuzz" is good.
I just feel like the first half was
like a little bit boring.
That's why I don't think it's as strong
as a "Shaun of the Dead."
And "Scott Pilgrim" I feel like is
the most Edgar Wright
film there is because-
- I feel "Scott Pilgrim" couldn't be made
by any other director.
- No, no, that's the thing, right?
I feel "Shaun of the Dead," Sean Penn...
Is that his name?
- Yeah, Sean Penn.
- Sean Penn and Nick...
- Cannon?
No.
- I was about to say Nick Fury,
then I was like, wait, that's not-
- [Ashley] You're thinking of Nick Frost.
- Nick Frost, that's it.
Nick Frost.
- [Ashley] You also said
Sean Penn not Simon Pegg.
- Oh, I said Sean Penn.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh no, Sean Penn is the
one that dies every movie!
- I was wondering who you were talking,
I was like, I don't think he's,
I'm trying to think
like when you said that.
- No, Sean Penn is not the
one that dies in every movie.
- Yeah, Sean Penn is
the one that always dies
in every movie.
- [Ashley] No, that's Sean Bean.
- Oh, that's Sean Bean.
(everyone laughs)
- Why is there so many Seans?
- Sean Penn is...
Who's Sean Penn?
- [Ashley] He was married to Robin Wright.
- Who the fuck is that?
- Whatever.
- We got a fucking living
IMDb page right here.
- [Ashley] She played Kevin Spacey's wife
in "House of Cards."
- I haven't seen "House of Cards."
- I've seen "House of Cards."
- Okay, but going back to "Scott Pilgrim,"
the reason I put this on is
'cause like I do really,
really fucking like "Shaun of the Dead."
But I feel like "Scott Pilgrim" is
just the most Edgar Wright
movie to exist at the moment.
It's him on like his best form.
And I feel like,
this movie kind of, like,
I feel like defined a
whole generation of nerds.
Like, you've seen so many people
who just base their
entire fucking personality
on this one movie.
You know who you are.
You know who you fucking are.
Like, you meet that person at like,
you meet one person like that
at like every anime convention you go to.
- [Joey] Of course, yeah.
- But-
- Well, I mean, I think the
reason why it works so well
is because like again,
Edgar Wright's like way
of directing is very
like over-exaggerated and like
very not rooted in reality.
And that works perfectly
with "Scott Pilgrim"
'cause "Scott Pilgrim" is based
off of fucking comic books.
It's very comicy.
- Was this the first Edgar
Wright film you watched?
- No, "Shaun of the Dead."
Like, I literally watched his movies like
from the beginning,
I mean, I watched "Spaced"
before "Shaun of the Dead."
So I'm like, I've known of them
for like a very, very long time.
- I think most people
in our age group started
with "Shaun of the Dead," right?
- I really like "Hot Fuzz."
I don't know why.
- "Hot Fuzz" is really good.
- I mean, it's a really good film.
- I think that's maybe my favorite.
- I feel like it's, out of
like the Cornetto trilogy,
it's like the middle favorite for me.
It's like "Shaun of the Dead, "Hot Fuzz,"
then I can't remember the third one then.
- [Ashley] "The World's End."
- "World's End," that's it!
- Well, I also, I think "Hot
Fuzz" is like where I grew up,
those kinds of towns.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like, "Oh shit, that is real."
- It's very much like if
you're not like familiar
with British, like, comedy-
- It's literally like they ripped my town.
I know they didn't but
it's very much similar to-
- I feel like that was the
vibe they were going for.
- That's why "Hot Fuzz" like
barely made it big in the US
'cause like, you know,
a lot of the references
Americans don't get.
- I mean, I feel like "Shaun of the Dead"
and "Hot Fuzz' were both
very much cult hits.
Because they're very much
ingrained in British humor
and British culture, you know.
You watch "Hot Fuzz" and
you probably can get a vibe
of what the place like he
grew up in, which is like-
- Nothing bad happens here.
- Yeah.
It's just like not something you can say
for many other British films even.
I mean people, when
people think British films
or British culture, they're like,
"Oh, it's like 'Harry Potter,' right?
"Everything's like 'Harry
Potter' over there."
- Everyone's just wizarding.
- Yeah, but I think another thing
that's been lost through time was
just how fucking unpopular this was
when this first came out.
Because now it's just like nerd culture.
Ha ha mainstream nerd culture.
Hi, I'm a nerd guys.
I identify as a nerd.
But I remember when I
first saw this in theaters,
I saw this by myself in a
completely empty theater
in Brighton.
- Wow, really?
- Because nobody wanted
to see this fucking movie!
- Was it a marketing issue?
- Huh?
- Maybe.
- Maybe the nerds just didn't
want to expose themselves.
Except for Garnt who's
like, "Fuck you, dude."
- Normally, it's normally
a marketing issue,
especially if it's a good movie.
- I mean, this movie fucking
bombed in the cinemas.
It was only afterwards-
- Definitely a cult.
- It definitely became a
cult movie that got picked up
and more people watched
as like nerd culture
became more mainstream.
But I remember the first
time watching this,
it blew my fucking mind how good this was.
And I couldn't tell anyone about it
'cause nobody was
interested in watching it.
- Just tell them to watch it.
- How do I sell this?
How would you sell this to someone?
Like, go back 20 years.
How do you sell this to someone,
to like one of your mates or something?
- Just tell them it's really good.
You wanna watch it again.
(Garnt laughs)
- "So what's it like?
"What's it like?
"Tell me."
- "I'll just take you.
"Just shut up."
- "Shut up and I'll take you.
"Don't expect anything."
- "Buy some popcorn and have a good time."
- "Is it like the fooey?"
- No, fuck off.
(Garnt laughs)
"Space Jam," you already
mentioned that you grew up with it
and whatnot.
What about "Matrix" there?
- "The Matrix," I mean...
- Do you really feel that
strongly about "The Matrix?"
- Honestly as a kid, yeah, I did.
- As a kid, yeah.
I feel like it's one of those things
where I just care about
it as like referential.
Like, it's so famous and so referenced.
But now I don't really give
a shit about "The Matrix."
- Yeah, I didn't really give a-
- It was revolutionary when it came out.
It was like, "Whoa, you can do that?"
- I'm also biased.
That fucking scene
where they put the thing
inside of the stomach gave
me nightmares as a kid.
- I've already talked about that, yeah.
That fucking gave me nightmares.
I will say, I don't think "The
Matrix" has aged very well.
- Oh no, definitely not.
Especially the first one.
- I've definitely rewatched
it and I'm just like,
"Oh God, I thought this was really cool."
I thought this was like the
coolest thing when it came out
'cause that's why-
- It's kind of shit.
It's kind of shit.
- It definitely hasn't aged well.
- It definitely has not aged well.
- But that's because there's
been since "The Matrix,"
there's been a million "Matrix" clones
that are just shot better.
- But I mean, like I feel like
part of the big reason I got
into anime was because
of "The Matrix' as well.
'Cause I'm just like, I see this,
and then this was like my
anime taste for a long time
because I thought this was cool as shit,
and I wanted to find
more things like this.
- Just iconic as fuck really.
- It's iconic as fuck.
And I remember, I think
the first time I saw this,
when did this come out?
1999?
- '97, I think.
- Okay, I think I was like nine or 10
when I first saw this.
Way too young to be seeing this.
But I remember thinking this
was like the coolest thing,
which it was.
- It was.
- For the time.
- Yeah, for the time, yeah.
- Showing your age there, Garnt.
- When he like pulls the red
and blue pill, it was like,
"Which one is he gonna pick?"
- I thinK by my age
when I was old enough to
be able to appreciate it,
it'd kind of fallen out.
- Oh, definitely because-
- I was like, what, like 16?
So that was like eight years ago.
- At that time, right,
there'd already been a
million clones of "Matrix."
- By the time that came out for you,
people who would dress like the people
in "The Matrix" are like
neckbeards holding a katana
with like a fedora, right?
If "The Matrix" was made nowadays,
it's just like the person
who's just learned the way of the blade.
- I didn't really watch many, like,
nerd movies though growing up.
Like, I never watched-
- What defines a nerd movie?
- Yeah, what defines nerd movie?
- "Star Wars."
I've still yet to watch the
original "Star Wars" trilogy.
- Really?
Or like "Lord of the Rings"
or anything like that?
- I love "Lord of the Rings."
I mean, that's probably
the nerdiest of nerd-
- I haven't watched "Lord of the Rings."
- The fuck?
- You haven't watched "Lord of the Rings?"
- Wait, what's weirder,
not watching "Star Wars"
or "Lord of the Rings?"
- You haven't watched "Star Wars?"
- Okay, you're both fucking weird to me!
You haven't watched "Star Wars,"
you haven't watch "Lord of the Rings."
- I feel like you have to
watch "Lord of the Rings."
- I feel like you have
to watch "Star Wars"
in that sense then.
- No, you don't.
- You don't have to, okay.
You don't have to watch
one, two, and three
just at least four, five, six.
- Yeah, I've only watched
one, two, and three.
(Joey laughs)
- I don't count that as
watching "Star Wars."
- I've not watched the original trilogy.
- You have to watch the original trilogy.
- I just don't give a shit.
- If you sat through 12
hours of "Lord of the Rings,"
you can sit through
three "Star Wars" movies.
- I used to watch like the director's cut
of "Lord of the Ring" back to back.
- It's like 15 hours.
- Back when we used to car journey,
we used to go to France every holiday.
It was a 12 hour journey.
And I was like,
like longer than 12.
So, I was like,
"Great, I'll watch the 'Lord
of the Rings' director cuts
"back to back in one sitting."
I used to do that like on the
way there and on the way back.
- I like "Lord of the Rings,"
but that's too much "Lord
of the Rings" for me.
- Honestly the reason
I haven't watched "Lord of the Rings" is,
okay, I have watched the first movie.
Fell asleep, thought it was
boring, never came back.
- Really?
- How old were you?
- When did it come out?
- The first one?
"Fellowship of the Ring" came
out in like mid-2000s, right?
- Yeah, wait.
- It's like 2003 or something, right?
- Yeah, something like that.
- So, I remember my cousin
watching it, and he was like-
- [Ashley] 'O1.
- '01.
Holy shit, that's a 20-year-old movie?
Sheesh.
- So, I think was about like 13, 14
when I attempted to watch
it, and I don't know, like-
- That's like the prime time though!
I feel.
- This is gonna sound weird
like coming from the isekai guy.
I just don't find fantasy
all that interesting.
- What the fuck?
That's all you fucking talk about.
That's all you talk about!
- Okay, okay, okay, okay.
- Watch it now.
You like fantasy now.
- Bring back Garnt.
This is not Garnt.
- Go back and watch it now.
- Anime fantasy, yeah.
I fucking fuck with that.
Real life fantasy, get
this shit out of my face.
- Oh my God, what a weeb.
(Garnt laughs)
What a fucking weeb.
- Bro, go watch it.
Actually give it a shot.
- "If it doesn't have hot anime
titties in an isekai world,
"I don't want it."
- Basically.
(everyone laughs)
- I appreciate the honesty.
- Is the main character overpowered?
No, Frodo's like, Frodo can't do shit.
- That's why it's so good.
- That's why it's good because he fights
through all of these
like insanely impossible
to survive situations with
the power of friendship, bro.
- Every single movie has
just amazing scenes in it.
- Dude, Sam, best waifu.
I'm just saying right now.
He's best waifu, dude.
He supPorts Frodo from start to finish.
- What's your favorite "Lord
of the Rings" movie, Joey?
- Probably third one.
- See, this is what I mean,
you can say any one of those
movies is the best movie,
and I'm like, "That's totally fair."
Like, every single movie is great.
- Yeah, all three movies are fantastic.
- So good.
You gotta watch it.
- Yeah, maybe.
- We should watch it together.
- It's long though.
It's long.
- We don't have to watch
the director's cut and shit.
We can watch the normal ones,
which is still like 10 hours,
but still.
- No, no.
The director's cut can
only really be appreciated
after you've loved the first cut
because they didn't want the bonus stuff.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You need to make sure you love it first.
- Okay, I'm sitting you down
to watch "Lord of the Rings,"
I'm sitting you down to watch "Star Wars."
- No, no, no.
I don't think you do.
- I don't feel like
"Star Wars" is necessary.
- Honestly, I'm...
Okay, I've pissed off
"Lord of the Rings" fans.
(Joey laughs)
Let me piss off "Star Wars" fans.
- Say it, Garnt.
- I prefer the prequels.
- [Ashley] What?
(everyone laughs)
- I've never just silenced a room so fast.
- That was the loudest one
second silence I ever heard.
- I know the plot to the original trilogy
and like Darth Vader.
I just think Darth Vader
looks fucking boring.
Like, I've played the Lego
games, so I know the story.
- "So, I basically know 'Star Wars' guys."
- I know the story and I just think
that like Darth Maul, fucking bad ass.
- Okay, to be fair-
- General Grievous,
only the coolest-
- Count Dooku?
- Count Dooku's meh.
General Grievous is the coolest
fucking "Star Wars" character.
- To be fair, to be fair-
- Jar Jar Binks, amazing.
(everyone laughs)
- If we're gonna say our hot
takes on like "Star Wars,"
I'm just gonna say it,
I think "Episode I" is
actually really fucking good.
- I think, well, obviously,
because I prefer the prequels.
- Darth Maul fight and the podracing is
like the two greatest
scenes in "Star Wars."
- Honestly, because the
reason I prefer the prequels,
to defend myself is, okay, number one,
I really don't give a
shit about "Star Wars."
- I couldn't care less about "Star Wars."
- [Joey] That's fair.
- It's just not something
I'm interested in.
- I'm not passionate
about "Star Wars" either.
- The Lego games are just bangers.
(everyone laughs)
They're great.
- True.
- And it's just like, I remember watching,
I've actually seen the
original trilogy a lot of times
because someone's always
got it on in the background.
Someone's always watching
it at some fucking family,
family gathering or something.
Or it's like playing at Christmas.
I don't know why.
But someone's always watching it,
so I've seen it so many fucking times.
And I kind of find it like just boring.
It's just a very standard
movie with like, it's just...
What's original about
"Star Wars" nowadays?
- Well, nowadays it's not
because again very much like "Matrix"
it's just been copied to shit.
- Yeah, it's kind of just
like "The Matrix" to me
where it's just, to me
it's just boring now.
It's just a very normal standard movie,
and it's just like, yeah,
Luke goes on a hero's journey
and Darth Vader is the
villain and yada yada yada.
- That's why I never like cared
to watch episodes seven, eight and nine
because in my mind, I'm just like,
it's not really like a fantasy to-
- Is nine out?
- [Ashley] It's been out since what...
- See, I don't even know.
- Didn't people like
hate the last two movies?
- I think so, yeah.
"Episode VII" was the only
one were people were like,
"It was pretty good."
- Yeah, but like, to me,
there are so many like scenes
in the prequels that just stand out to me.
Like, that fucking duel with Darth Maul
and like fucking Qui-Gon Jinn and Obi-Wan.
Holy shit!
That is iconic!
- That fight to this day
still is the best fight scene
in "Star Wars" and it has the best theme.
- Oh my God.
- The Darth Maul theme, dude!
- Yeah, yeah.
- Darth Maul was terrifying as well.
- Darth Maul was fucking-
- Fuck the Darth Vader theme.
- Fuck Darth Vader.
What's scary about someone having asthma?
Like, fucking...
I have asthma.
Does that make me fucking scary?
No, fuck that.
- Also in the prequels,
we didn't get to see Anakin kill the kids.
I like that part.
(Joey laughs)
- Like, are you kidding me?
Like, the first time you see, like,
Count Dooku fight Yoda, holy shit, man.
That was, to me, that was like
by far the one "Star Wars-"
- The only thing that irks me
about the original three episodes is that
Yoda is literally a puppet.
- General Grievous wasn't
in all of them.
- Yoda is literally a puppet.
- People love that though.
- Yeah, I know.
I don't get that.
I prefer when he's like, you
know, has emotion in his face.
- I liked him when he was fucking shit up!
- Yeah, when he was like
flipping in the air and shit.
- When he brings out the lightsaber
and he starts doing
fucking like gymnastics
and all this shit.
- Also I love Samuel L. Jackson though.
- Yes, Samuel L. Jackson.
- Samuel L. Jackson is the only thing
that made "The Clone Wars" bearable.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- When he pulls out the purple lightsaber,
I was like, "My man!
"Let's go!"
- It's like the coolest,
the only thing I actually gave a shit
about "Star Wars" was the jedis,
and what's not in the fucking,
like what's hardly in the original trilogy
and like the sequels?
It's the jedis!
That's what I want.
I want to see cool jedis fights.
I want to see cool lightsaber fights.
- Also all the best memes
come from the prequels.
- That's true.
It did get memed to shit.
- So yeah, I'm sticking by my gun.
I prefer the "Star Wars" prequels.
Come at me "Star Wars" fans.
- I wonder how many dislikes
this clip's gonna have.
(everyone laughs)
- "Star Wars" is kind of boring.
- Fair.
I'm not gonna sit here and pretend
like it's the greatest
fantasy story ever written.
But I mean, you know, it's dece.
- I mean, that's the biggest thing.
I'm more passionate about
not caring about "Star Wars"
and like "Lord of the
Rings" I've seen some of
like the action scenes,
and I'm like, I could
probably get into it.
There's just-
- Oh, the battles.
Bruh!
- The battles are fucking everything.
- Battle of Helm's Deep.
Bro!
Got me acting up.
- So good.
(everyone laughs)
- Battles are so good!
- "Lord of the Rings"
battles make me act up.
- Yo, we still haven't had battles
as good as "Lord of the Rings."
It's been like 20 years
and nothing has come close.
- Dude, give me another hour
and a half long fight scene,
man, I need that in my life.
- It's insane, bro.
That guy literally pitched
that and they were like,
"All right, let's do it."
- "So you want the fight
scene to be how long?"
- And they fucking did it.
- They did it.
- What's this?
- It's an hour and a half battle scene.
And it's fucking amazing.
- That doesn't cut away
to anything.
It's literally an hour
and a half of fighting.
- It's fucking amazing.
- All right, I guess you sold me.
I guess that's all I need.
- They still build character
and story in a battle
without like bullshit disbelief of,
"What's going on?
"Is everything okay?"
It's like literally they're
like in the middle of fucking-
- They're literally monologuing
as they're fighting.
- I actually remember
why I stopped watching "Lord
of the Rings" (laughs) 'cause,
'cause I was actually
watching it with my cousin.
And so they go on this
journey and I kept asking,
"Are they there yet?"
(everyone laughs)
And he literally got so
fucking pissed off with me.
'Cause I was just like,
"Are they there yet?
"When are they gonna get there?
"Are they close to coming there?"
And he's like, "Garnt, shut the fuck up!"
(everyone laughs)
- You also can't watch "Lord of the Rings"
with someone who is a giga fan.
You need someone to shut the
fuck up when you're watching.
- That's my pet peeve.
- Please, please-
- People who love "Lord of the Rings,"
unfortunately will tell you everything
about "Lord of the Rings"
throughout every single moment.
- Yeah, please don't be that guy
who just quotes the movie as it happens.
I literally can't stand it.
- That is my least favorite thing.
- And like what's even
worse is like not even
when they're quoting out loud,
when they think they're
being conspicuous about it
and they just like start
mouthing to themselves.
(everyone laughs)
- No, the one I hate more is
when they whisper to themselves
right before it happens.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I get it, you've seen
this movie 17,000 times.
Shut the fuck up.
- I hate when people are
like, "Oh, this part's good."
It's like, well, I'll decide that.
Don't tell me this part's good.
I'm about to fucking watch it.
I'll decide if this part is good.
- Don't be that guy please.
- I mean, I've...
You know, you always have that part
where you show someone
a movie you really like,
but I try to be as
subtle about it as I can.
Because like, in my mind, I'm like,
"This good part's coming up."
And I'll like try to like
see on the corner of my eye
if they're watching it.
Like, if I was invisible,
I'd be like full on Elmo.
You know?
Like.
- Don't look at me like that.
- That's the other pet peeve I have
when I'm showing a movie
to a friend or whoever
and in my head, I'm like,
"Oh, this next scene, they're gonna love."
And I look over and they're
just out on their phone.
Don't be that guy.
- Yeah, don't be that guy.
- Etiquette, come on.
Movie etiquette.
- But anyway, that's my three by three.
These are not my favorite films,
well some of these I fuck with still.
Some of these are just
there because (laughs)
- Well, I mean, they're
your childhood movies.
- They're my childhood movies.
- That's what three by three's all about.
- This episode is sponsored by us!
- Trash Taste!
We have mugs now!
- Trash Taste Mug!
Mugs!
- On a scale of one to 10,
how much do you want to
drink tea out of this mug?
- 10 out of 10.
It comes with its own lid
to keep beverages warm.
- Oh my God, the lid comes off.
What?
- Not only is this
a collector's item,
I mean, look at this thing.
This would look amazing on your shelf.
It's also highly practical.
It's a good size mug.
- Look at this.
This is so good, I've
already been drinking coffee
out of it.
This is a used mug.
- [Joey] It looks disgusting.
- I'm sorry for promoting a used mug.
- Holy shit, Garnt.
Fuck me.
Thank God that it's ceramic
and really easy to clean up.
- [Joey] How many times did
you miss your mouth there?
- You've seen how I sip, Joey.
(everyone laughs)
- Now you can reenact that meme.
- While Garnt sips disgustingly,
you can get your own Trash Taste mug.
Oh my God.
It's beautiful, it's beautiful material.
- $29.99 plus shipping.
And I think it's limited, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- For a limited time, so
get them while they last.
- And the first thousand people
who order one of these mugs
will get a personal letter
from us.
- And it's got a little Trash
Taste logo on the bottom.
- I can't show you
'cause I've literally
still got coffee in here.
- Guys, you can only preorder these
for the next three weeks.
So, if you want your
very own Trash Taste mug,
this is the only chance to get it
and it's for the next three weeks.
And once they're gone, we're
not bringing them back.
- So you can preorder them right now.
Go down to TrashTasteMugs.com,
link's down in the description below.
And support the boys
and get yourself you're
very own Trash Taste mug.
- So you can watch Trash Taste
and drink your Trash Taste
mug with us while we drink
from our Trash Taste mug.
- You can really feel like
you're part of the boys
with this.
- By going to TrashTasteMugs.com.
- Don't be a peasant.
Drink like a king
with Trash Taste mugs.
- Get four Trash Taste
mugs for the whole family,
for the set.
- Only mouth breathers don't
drink out of Trash Taste mugs.
- Does your mug have a lid?
I don't think so.
This one has a lid.
- This one has a lid and
it's a fantastic lid.
- Buy a Trash Taste mug!
What are you doing?
- Link's in the description.
Back to the episode.
- All right, Joey.
Who is next?
Oh, should I do it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Joey] All right, who's next?
Me or Connor?
- Joey is next.
I swear I'm always last, right?
- Yeah, you are.
- Why is that?
All right, well, hopefully
mine won't be too pretentious.
(everyone laughs)
What?
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- Is mine pretentious?
I don't know.
- At first I saw "Apocalypse
Now" and I'm just like,
did you just go through the IMDb top 250?
- Okay, so I'll go through them.
So, from top left to bottom
right we have "King's Speech,"
"Rashomon," "Bruce Almighty,"
"Apocalypse Now," "Pulp Fiction,"
"Goodfellas," "Austin Powers Goldmember,"
"Gladiator," and "Kamera o Tomeru na."
- Okay, I've seen every
English speaking movie.
- I had a feeling you'd put Japanese.
- What are these Japanese movies?
- What are these Nihongo movies?
I say that as I put one on mine.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, so which ones have
you guys seen and not seen?
- All of these except for,
I don't think I've seen "Apocalypse Now."
- Oh, you've never seen "Apocalypse Now?"
- Actually I haven't seen
"Apocalypse Now" either.
- [Joey] What?
- The two Japanese films.
- Okay, so like as I was saying earlier,
like I always have that
like top three movies
in case anyone at like
a panel always asks me.
And my top three that I always
bring up is "Apocalypse Now,"
"Pulp Fiction," and "Goodfellas."
- I mean, those are all
fucking bangers, honestly.
- I mean, this is top 10 IMDb films.
- I don't even know.
- I feel like "Goodfellas"
and "Pulp Fiction"
definitely are like top 20.
- Oh yeah, "Goodfellas"
and "Pulp Fiction" are
definitely up there.
- I've never, wait, no, I
haven't watched "Goodfellas."
- Oh, you've never seen "Goodfellas?"
- I've never watched "The
Godfather" or "Goodfellas."
- [Joey] Oh really?
- Yeah, have you not?
- You know how you said like
sometimes you just save a movie
that you just know you're gonna love?
I'm just like, you know, I don't
need to watch it right now,
but I know I will and
I know I'll enjoy it.
- Yeah.
I mean, like, I feel like
if we're going through like
that IMDb thing, like
most people are like,
"Oh yeah, 'Godfather.'"
Like, the "Godfather" trilogy, yeah,
that's definitely one of those.
And it's like, the
"Godfather" trilogy is good
and like, I like a lot
of Martin Scorsese films.
But I think out of all
of them, "Goodfellas,"
it's a tie for me between
"Goodfellas" and "Casino."
- Oh, I feel like
"Casino" is so underrated.
- Yeah, "Casino" I feel is a very
underrated Martin Scorsese film.
But I put "Goodfellas"
there because it was like-
- It's the classic.
- It's the classic, it
was the first, like-
- Safe.
Safe is what I'm seeing here, Joey.
- It was the first Martin
Scorsese like gangster film
I ever watched.
And then like, you know,
and then obviously I went
back after that and was like,
I'll watch "Godfather" and "Taxi
Driver" and like all those.
- I think the thing about
"Godfather" is that,
I obviously recognize it as a good movie,
but there's a difference
between me being like,
"Oh, this is a really good
movie" to "This is a movie
"that I really personally enjoy."
And for me, "Godfather" is like something
that I could recognize as really good.
It was just a bit slow sometimes.
I feel like Martin
Scorsese gangster films is
just "Godfather" but just
a bit more condensed,
a bit more snappy, you know?
I mean, I mean, yeah.
- Martin Scorsese did "The Departed?"
- Yeah, he did "Departed" as well.
- And that's probably one of my favorite.
- That's a fantastic film.
I mean, again, everything he's made,
like "Wolf of Wall Street"
as well was fantastic.
- Martin Scorsese is just-
- He's just a really,
really good filmmaker.
- Consistent.
- "Raging Bull" as well was another one.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Basically every movie you can think of
that has Robert De Niro in
it, probably a Scorsese film.
- Honestly Robert De Niro and Joe Pesci is
just like one of the best duos.
Like, you see them together
and you know it's gonna be a banger film.
- The part that killed me
though was like, I remember,
'cause I was telling Aki about
this, the "Goodfellas" movie,
'cause she'd never seen it before,
and she was like, "Who's in it?"
And I was like,
"Oh, you know, Robert De
Niro and like Joe Pesci."
She was like, "Yeah, I know."
And then I was like, "Oh, and
Ray Liotta is in it as well."
And she's like, "Oh yeah, I
know that guy from 'Bee Movie.'"
(everyone laughs)
- How does she know that?
- 'Cause she loves "Bee Movie!"
And I'm like, "You're dead to me."
(everyone laughs)
- Oh, that poor man.
- Ray Liotta's legacy is
literally "Goodfellas"
and "Bee Movie."
- And "Bee Movie."
(everyone laughs)
- 'Cause I deadass can't think
of another Ray Liotta movie.
I'm sure he's been in a
bunch of other movies.
- I know I've seen him in other things.
I just can't think of it
off the top of my head.
- But I mean like I don't really have
to explain "Pulp Fiction."
It's like one of the most
cult classic fucking-
- I like cinema.
- It's like, I swear to
God, it was like either,
if you want to look like
you have a personality
in university, you put a
Quentin Tarantino poster
on your wall.
- It's either a "Pulp Fiction" poster
or a "Reservoir Dogs" poster.
- I put a Tarantino film on my list,
so I guess we can debate
it when we get to that.
Which one is the-
- I mean, I've seen
everything by Tarantino.
He's like one of my favorite directors,
but I still think to this day,
"Pulp Fiction" is, in my
personal opinion, is my favorite.
It's really close between "Pulp Fiction"
and "Reservoir Dogs."
- I still put "Reservoir Dogs."
- I'll save my points for mine.
- We'll save that debate.
And then "Apocalypse Now"
is my favorite war film.
- What's the plot of "Apocalypse Now?"
- What's it even about?
- So, "Apocalypse Now" is
based on the Vietnam War.
- Yeah, that's all I know about it.
- With like basically the,
it's told from the American side
where like American troops are told,
so Martin Sheen is the main character,
and he is like set on a mission
to go and pick up a soldier
from like, he's like a vet.
- Who's the director?
- Francis Ford Coppola.
- It's the same person
who made "Godfather."
- Oh.
- So, Francis Ford Coppola,
like this is like one of his
most famous films, I think.
Did you know that Francis Ford Coppola is
actually the uncle to Nicholas Cage?
- What?
- Yeah, random fact I
found out the other day.
But anyway, so basically it's set
where like Martin Sheen's
character's team has to go
into the Vietnam forest to
go and look for this like vet
who holds a lot of information
about the Vietnam War.
Basically he's kind of gone insane
and is living in the Vietnam like-
- 'Cause it's Marlon Brando, right?
- Marlon Brando.
Basically, it's, yeah.
So, Marlon Brando's
character is this like Viet
like soldier vet
who like holds a lot of information
and like he needs to be
brought back to the US army.
Basically Martin Sheen's
character goes in,
tries to fight off all the Vietcong
and, you know, tries to
get him back basically.
But as Martin Sheen's character is going
through all of these like
life and death situations,
stuff like that, he too also
slowly starts to lose his mind.
And then eventually, and then, you know,
that poster there is pretty much-
- Fucking awesome poster.
- Yeah, pretty much sums up.
Like, that scene where he
like comes out of the pool
as there's like fighting happening is
one of the coolest
fucking scenes in cinema.
- I wanna watch that.
That sounds cool.
- Marlon Brando is like
fantastic, Martin Sheen is-
- Is it a thinky movie?
- How much do I have to
think during this movie?
- Well, okay, so "Apocalypse Now" has
like a director's cut called
"Apocalypse Now Redux,"
which is like three and a half hours long.
- How long is the original?
- Three hours.
- Oh.
- Yeah.
So, it's still a long movie.
- Because here's the thing
about "Apocalypse Now"
'cause everything you described
I already kind of knew about it.
'Cause I knew like the
basic plot description
and everything like that.
What makes it good?
- Okay, so in my opinion
what makes it really good is
just the, well, first of all, it's like,
the music choice in that
movie is fucking brilliant.
It's like everything I fucking love.
Like, in my opinion,
"Apocalypse Now" still has
one of the greatest opening scenes
of any movie.
- Iconic, iconic.
- Very iconic.
But I don't know.
It's also just like, again,
it's like it takes that
like kind of war element
and weirdly enough,
it's a Vietnam War film
that doesn't really have
a whole lot of fighting.
Like, really the most
amount of like fighting
between the US army and
Vietnam really happens
in like the first like maybe 20 minutes.
And then the rest of
the movie is literally
just you're inside the mind
of Martin Sheen's character
as he's like slowly
venturing closer and closer
to his target and he's
slowly like losing his mind
as a result of war.
And it's like a very, like, I don't know.
It's like a really weird
like psychological twist
on a war movie that you don't really,
'cause when you think of a war movie,
you think of like "Saving Private Ryan,"
where like, yeah, there's
obviously a lot of like, you know,
soldiers getting fucked
up in the war scenes.
But like there's also a lot
of like fighting scenes.
Like, gun fighting scenes
or whatever the fuck it is.
Whereas "Apocalypse
Now" doesn't really have
a whole lot of that.
It's like, it's almost like
a psychological horror set
during the Vietnam War.
And I think that's what makes,
personally that's what makes
it really interesting to me.
- 'Cause the thing is I think I know more
about "Apocalypse Now"
than actually seeing the movie itself.
'Cause I know like,
I think this has like a
really interesting story
behind how it was made
because like I think,
the director himself I
think almost went bankrupt
making this movie or something like that.
Because he had to like convince
the studio that he owns
or something to like lend him
the money to make this movie.
And he was out there for like months
and months shooting this movie
and it almost wasn't made.
And I think like Marlon Brando
just refused to read the script.
- Yeah, Marlon Brando refused
to remember his lines.
- He's been notorious for that.
- But this was the first movie
where he started to become like this.
And then "The Godfather" I think happened
after "Apocalypse Now" which like then,
or was it the other way around?
- I think it was the other way around.
- It might've been the other way around.
But basically, yeah,
Marlon Brando doesn't appear in this movie
until maybe about two and a half hours in.
- I think like most of his
lines are just like ad-libbed
because he just refused
to remember his lines.
I'm just like, how does that work?
How does that work?
- I don't think I've ever
seen any of the movies
that he's in,
but I know that he's like notorious
for being awful to work with.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, you know, like during his prime
obviously he was a fantastic,
and you know, he's still a
fantastic actor in this movie
as well, but it's like,
it's very clear that he's
not like at his peak.
But I feel like Martin Sheen's performance
in this movie is just so God damn good
that like he does such
an amazing job of like
really like progressively
showing someone going insane.
I don't know.
My opinion, fantastic movie.
- I remember, I think he
was on Joe Rogan I think...
- Martin Sheen?
- No, no, no, no, no.
Robert Downey Jr. Was on
it and he was talking about
that sometimes he didn't remember lines.
I think when he did...
Which I think "Sherlock" he
remembered all his lines.
But other movies he was just
like, "Put an earpiece in.
"Just feed me my lines."
- Honestly, especially
when he's like Iron Man,
he's just acting Robert Downey Jr.
- He was saying, you know,
some films don't require
me to get that deep
into their character so there's no point
in spending all this
time learning the lines.
But like, I think for like "Sherlock,"
it was like quite difficult,
some of the lines in the
way that he was doing it
so he wanted to learn it.
He was just like, "Yeah,
it depends on the movie."
But the way he made it
sound made it seem like,
oh, that makes sense.
Then when you hear about
like the third party accounts
of Marlon Brando, it's like,
oh my God, this sounds like fucking hell.
- Yeah, right.
And I bet like, you know,
'cause there's a lot
of big actors in this,
like Harrison Ford's
in this movie as well.
- This before he's angry at everything?
- This is before he's angry.
(everyone laughs)
Yeah, but like, I don't know.
Just really, really good
movie in my opinion.
And then-
- "The King's Speech?"
- I was surprised.
That came out of nowhere
'cause I've never-
- What, "King's Speech?"
- I've never heard Joey
mention this film ever.
- Okay, so to be fair,
this is probably the most
recent film I watched
that really made a massive
impact on me 'cause-
- Is it 'cause Aki's obsessed
with the Royal family?
- No, it's because Aki's
obsessed with biopics.
- Ah.
- So before I met Aki,
I never really cared to
watch a lot of like biopics.
Biopics are like movies based off
of real people's lives essentially.
And so I watched a shitload
of biopics with Aki.
So, like "Imitation Game" was
another one I was thinking
of putting here.
Like, "Theory of Everything"
is another great movie.
But I don't know, something
about "King's Speech,"
I mean, firstly, I fucking
love Geoffrey Rush.
He's like one of my favorite actors.
Like, everything that he had,
and he does such a fucking
good job in this movie as well.
And I don't know, it's just like,
it's a really simple movie,
but it's just the acting in this is
just so God damn believable.
It's just so good.
- I've never actually watched it.
But I also, when I was
growing up my best mate
for like my whole childhood
had like a really bad stutter.
So I always had to order for
him at things and everything.
I don't know, this movie came out
and I think it was a big deal.
- I think it won best
picture at the Oscars.
- Yeah, it did.
I mean, like, the only reason I knew a lot
about stuttering was,
again, my best mate had it
and had to go to a bunch
of like therapy and stuff
to try and get it.
'Cause he was like, you know,
like even like at like
16, 17, 18 couldn't like,
you know, order at places.
And so I just got used to doing it.
And then yeah, it was really interesting
'cause I think in the movie
they kind of like gloss over it.
But like in real life,
the way that you like you can solve it,
there's like so many different methods.
My mate had to wear like a belt,
like a big belt around his chest
to make his breathing different
so that he wouldn't stutter.
- Oh wow.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, the movie
actually does go through
like all the actual steps that-
- Okay, I haven't seen it so I don't know.
- That the king actually had to go through
and stuff like that.
And like, I don't know.
It's really interesting as well.
And it's just cool to
think that like a lot
of this stuff actually
happened in real life.
At the end, like King George?
What's his name?
- I can't remember.
- I don't know, whatever
the king's name was,
like actually got over
his stutter in real life
as a result of this dude who
just, you know, solved it.
And I don't know, it's just,
like, it's very like,
because you like meticulously watch
through like every single step
and every failure of the king trying
to get over his stutter,
it's just like the ending
speech is just really powerful
and like really rewarding being like,
"Fuck yeah, dude, you nailed that shit.
"My man, let's go!"
- I mean, I saw it a while ago
and I just remember it was a good movie.
- I think this movie got me into biopics.
- [Garnt] Oh, okay.
- I was like, okay, you know what?
Biopics might be kinda cool.
- I'm glad you guys didn't
put any like documentaries
or anything.
I was like, we have to
save that for another time.
- Oh yeah.
- We'll save that for another.
- Yeah, we'll save that for another time.
- Connor would do like a fucking 10 by 10.
- I'll bring a 100 by 100 for you, Garnt.
- Can I just do like a one by one?
It's just "Supersize Me."
(everyone laughs)
And then obviously "Bruce
Almighty" we're talking
about like, who hasn't
seen "Bruce Almighty?"
- It's like Morgan Freeman as God.
I still think of Morgan Freeman as God.
Just because of "Bruce Almighty."
- It's like the most 2000s film ever.
- It is like the quintessential
Jim Carrey movie.
- When did it come out?
Might've come out in 90s.
But I think of this
like encapsulates the
feeling of the 2000s.
- Exactly, like everyone in it is amazing.
It's still funny to this day.
- [Ashley] '03.
- '03, God damn.
- Because of this movie,
if I die and I don't see Morgan
Freeman at the pearly gates.
I'll just want to refund on life.
- I'll be like, "Take me to hell."
(everyone laughs)
- "I specifically died
with the expectation
"that Morgan Freeman
would be here waiting."
- And then what's another obvious one.
I mean, "Austin Powers Goldmember."
- Before we get to these ones,
explain the Japanese films.
- The Japanese ones, okay.
- Explain the Nihongos.
- [Joey] Wait, which one
do you want to hear about?
- [Connor] First one, the top one.
- [Joey] The top one, okay.
So "Rashomon," so this was during a time,
this was during like a very,
I guess pretentious period
of my high school life,
where I was like, I want to
watch a lot of really old films.
- Okay.
- Oh gosh.
- So "Rashomon" is one,
it's done by this guy
called Akira Kurosawa.
- Oh, it's an Akira Kurosawa.
- Yeah, it's an Akira Kurosawa film
who's known as like one of
the greatest film directors
of all time.
- Hello, I'm a film buff.
(everyone laughs)
Mention one name.
Hello, I'm a film buff.
- I'm a pretentious film buff.
So I sat down and watched
every Akira Kurosawa film
and "Rashomon" is one of them.
And it's essentially, it's
really hard to kind of explain.
But basically I think this
movie was made in like 1950,
I think.
Black and white film.
But basically it revolves
around this like one murder case
that happens in like Edo period Japan,
and the same I guess murder is told
from different perspectives
and different characters.
So like, it kind of plays around,
I don't know if it was the
first movie to ever do it,
but it kind of plays around
with the whole like
unreliable narrator like logic
that a lot of movies use now.
And it's just like, I don't know,
the cinematography in it is like,
it's hard to believe this
movie was made 70 years ago.
- Yeah, I mean, that's why
every fucking big director
and big film buff still says his name.
- Akira Kurosawa is
your favorite director's
favorite director.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, basically.
- And like, I feel "Rashomon"
was one of those movies
that like took everything
that Akira Kurosawa was
like really good at in
terms of filmmaking,
and just like crushed it
into like an hour 30
minute like solid movie.
And like, Mifune Toshiro is
like the guy in the poster
who's in like basically every
fucking Akira Kurosawa movie.
But like, he's one of my
favorite Japanese actors
just because like, I don't know.
He kinda, you know,
that like weird stigma of Japanese acting
where it's like way over the top
and like really unrealistic?
- We've talked about it.
- Which we talked about.
Like, Mifune Toshiro in my
opinion like kind of took that
and almost made it his own.
'Cause like every Mifune
Toshiro character is
like so over-exaggerated
in terms of like emotion
and like movement and stuff like that.
Like, I'd be very surprised
if he didn't do like theater
training and shit like that.
But like, I don't know,
it's over-exaggerated
but it's still like believable,
if that makes sense.
And it like, it becomes
really like kind of,
I don't know what the
right word for it is.
I know I sound very pretentious right now,
but it's a real-
- Go ahead, Joey.
- But like in my opinion,
like there's lots of really
good Akira Kurosawa movies.
- I think the only one I've
seen is "Seven Samurai."
- "Seven Samurai."
- The classic.
- That's a classic.
- Is that the one where that
like fight scene goes on
for so God damn long?
- That might be.
I mean, there's a lot of like-
- That was a really weird.
- There's a lot of fight scenes
in Akira Kurosawa movies.
- "Seven Samurai," did it have a remake?
- There was a western remake.
- There was a western remake,
also "The Magnificent Seven"
is the Western version
of that film, which is also a classic.
- I think maybe I watched,
what's it called, "13 Assassins,"
That's a remake right of...
- I don't know, actually.
- [Ashley] That is a different.
- That's a different story, is it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is there a really, really
long fight in "Seven Samurai?"
- I don't know about "Seven Samurai,"
but like the one that I can think of
that has a really long
flight is probably "Ran."
- You've probably seen "Seven Samurai"
if you've gone through,
if you went through the phase of going
through the IMDb top 250.
- You've probably seen about
five different Akira Kurosawa-
- I feel like I watched a
movie called "Seven Samurai"
that was in black and white,
and there was a fight scene
that was like two hours long.
And I was just like sitting there like,
"When is it gonna end?"
- I don't know about,
I don't think "Seven Samurai"
was even two hours long.
- No, it was.
It was like three and a half hours long.
- I don't remember.
- Is there a long fight
scene in "Seven Samurai?"
(everyone laughs)
- That was just a very
long movie in general.
- Can you Google it?
Like long fight scene-
- I mean, it's probably the
film you're thinking of.
- I just wanna know if I watched it.
- You've probably seen it.
It's a classic.
Like, it's definitely on the IMDb,
like there's probably about
five Akira Kurosawa films
if you go through the IMDb.
- No, it's actually only one.
It's only "Seven Samurai,"
I was about to say.
- Big sad, big sad.
- Because that's the only one
that's on the IMDb top 250.
So, that's the only one that
most people have only seen.
Even though he has like
such a wealth of work.
- Yeah, I mean, "Ran" was I
think his first color film
and that was also fucking fantastic.
I think the stigma is that a
lot of Akira Kurosawa films are
like based around like
samurai and shit like that.
When like later on in his career,
he did a lot of like kind of rooted more
in like modern day stuff.
There's another film
that I thought about putting
up there called "Ikiru"
which means to live.
And it's essentially this like
kind of coming of age story
of this old man who realizes
that he's like about to die
and basically like,
you know, the movie "The Bucket List"
with fucking Morgan
Freeman and Jack Nicholson.
I feel that completely
ripped off of "Ikiru"
because it's almost like,
'cause the concept is exactly the same.
It's like an old guy wanting
to like kind of rediscover his life
and like really like
give meaning to his life
on his death bed.
But like told in like a really like cool,
artistic Akira Kurosawa-esque way.
Yeah, I don't know.
- I mean, he's a legend for a reason
especially in the film industry.
- If you're a movie buff,
please watch Akira Kurosawa.
- What's this?
I've never...
- Okay, "Kamera o Tomeru
na" is a, there's this-
- Like a zombie movie, right?
- Yeah, so basically it's
this movie, have you seen it?
Yeah.
Okay, I was not expecting
anything out of this movie.
So I actually watched this film-
- When did it come out?
(Joey sighs)
- Quite, quite recently.
Like, a couple of years ago.
So, I thought it was just gonna be like,
okay, so the reason why I
think this movie is genius
is the way that it was marketed.
So the way that it's marketed,
you look at this poster and you think,
"Oh, it's a zombie film.
"Like, a B grade zombie
film kind of thing."
It's completely not.
It basically takes the zombie film thing
and turns it super fucking meta.
So basically what it is, it's like,
I don't want to give too much away,
but basically the movie opens
with this 15, 20 minute
one cut zombie film.
Like, there's no cuts in it whatsoever.
And then you think, oh, the
credit's roll and that's it.
But then what happens is it goes back,
and it shows you how that
one cut movie is made
but told in a fictional way.
It's really difficult,
it's really fucking meta.
It's basically-
- Ooh, that sounds cool.
- It's basically a movie on,
and there's like all sorts of like weird,
like it's actually a comedy.
There's also like there's all these
like weird comedic shenanigans
that happen behind the
scenes of them shooting
that one shot 20 minutes zombie film.
So, the movie is about
the making of that movie.
- That honestly sounds like
it's right up my alley.
- Yeah, I think you'd love it.
- I'm just like, this is, that's-
- Garnt wants to stop recording right now.
- I'll make a fucking video on this.
- I was not expecting this
movie to be good at all,
but it was, one, it's
really, really funny.
And two, again, like the
whole meta aesthetic of it,
I was like, whoa I've never.
And it gets even more meta
because during the credit scenes,
then there's a behind the
scenes camera of that camera.
So, it's like a movie within
a movie within a movie.
And it's like, I love it.
I just love like the whole
meta aesthetic of it.
But like I put this on
there because like for one,
I barely know anyone who's seen it.
- I've never even heard of it until now.
- I guess people will now.
- [Ashley] The English title
is "One Cut of the Dead."
- "One Cut of the Dead."
That sounds so cliche though.
- Yeah, but that's exactly it.
Like, it plays to the strengths
of zombie film cliches
and just completely flips it on his head
and just turns it into like
this wacky slapstick comedy.
- That sounds cool.
- Yeah, it's really, really cool.
- It sounds like an episode of
"Haruhi" or something, right?
- Honestly.
It's like if "Endless Eight" was good.
- [Ashley] Sorry, it came out in 2017.
I forgot.
- 2017.
- 2017, yeah.
- I feel like the last
zombie movie that I watched
that I really fucking
enjoyed was "Train to Busan."
- Oh, that's good.
- I haven't watched "Train to Busan."
- That's a fantastic movie.
- Fucking so good.
Like, I can't explain why it's really good
'cause it's just like a very,
like, it has like the same beats
as just a standard zombie movie,
but it's just a really good movie.
- Just a solid movie.
- It is a solid movie.
Even if like, you think you're
bored of the zombie genre,
like-
- I think I am.
- 'Cause I thought I was.
- Okay, if you're bored
of the zombie genre,
you need to watch that.
- And then I got to
watch "Train to Busan."
And then I gotta watch other shit too.
Fuck.
- No, but like "One Cut of the Dead,"
that was the title, right?
"One Cut of the Dead," like, yeah.
Like, I feel,
if there's any movie I can
recommend on my three by three,
it's probably that one
just because it's like-
- I like how we both put it
in the bottom right as well.
The bottom left, sorry.
- Like, it completely destroys
what you think about movies
in a way that's like really fun.
And also like, just again,
it's just meta as fuck.
If you love that whole meta thing,
like you'd love that film.
And then I put "Gladiator"
on there just 'cause it's-
- I probably would put "Gladiator" too.
It's a good film.
- It's fantastic.
- Yeah, it's just good.
- It's just very good.
- It's just good.
Like, there's no complaint.
Like, I don't have any like
special memories with the movie.
I just think it's really good.
- Just a clean story.
- I like history.
- It's not even history, right?
- I like tournament arcs.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, that's basically it, right?
- "Gladiator" is just a tournament arc.
- I like Russell Crowe, he's funny.
- Yeah, Russell Crowe is a great actor.
- I just realized, yeah,
this is basically just a fucking
shonen anime set in Rome,
and it's just condensed down into a movie.
- Dude, tournament arc, revenge story.
- [Garnt] Yeah!
- It's everything I want.
Russell Crowe.
It's everything I want.
- And I feel like it's this,
and I was like really
close to putting "300"
on mine as well.
- Actually I think I like "300" more.
- I feel like "Gladiator"
is the better film,
but I think "300" made
more of an impression.
- "300" is the more entertaining variety.
- Yeah, yeah.
Before like Zack Snyder thought like,
before Zack Snyder thought,
"I could put slow mo in everything.
"What if I just use it for everything?"
- "300" is so good.
- I'm not gonna lie, man,
the slow motion fight scene
in "300" still fucking slap
to this day.
- I still think it's Zack
Snyder's best film to this day.
- I 100% agree.
- Like, he just peeked with
that and he was just like,
"How do I recapture this?
"How do I do it?"
- "Let me do the same thing
with all my other films."
- It's just such a fun film.
- It is.
It's such a quotable, just
fun, like bloody, gory film.
- It's such a cool story too.
- It's just like-
- It's based off real life.
Fucking awesome.
- As much as we know.
- I mean, somewhat.
- You cannot like watch "300"
and not just come out just hyped as fuck.
Just wanting to fucking punch someone.
- The funniest thing about "300"
in my opinion is just how they made Xerxes
into this like nine foot
tall like brick shit house.
When I think in real life,
Xerxes was like four feet tall.
Like, he was actually a midget.
And Zack Snyder was like, "No, no.
"Let's get the biggest Chad
in the movie film industry
"and just they can play Xerxes."
- 'Cause I think, have you
been in a movie theater
where they've literally just gasped?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- 'Cause like "300" is the
only experience I've had
in a movie theater
where like the whole fucking
movie theater just gasped
and that was the scene, that
was like the very final scene
where he throws the spear.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- That was such a good scene.
God, that's such a good movie!
- God, I want to watch "300" again.
- It's such a good film.
- It's such a good movie.
- You can't not be happy
watching that film.
So fucking good.
- Such a quotable movie.
I mean, like all of these films like,
there's at least one quote I can easily,
one or two quotes I can talk.
- Let's get into this.
- "Austin Powers."
- Why?
- "Goldmember" though.
It's "Goldmember."
- What's up with that?
- I don't know, I think it's
the best "Austin Powers" movie.
- I don't really like "Austin Powers."
- You don't like "Austin Powers?"
I rewatched "Goldmember" again
just because like one of my
friends came over to my house
and was like, "I feel like
watching 'Goldmember.'"
And I was like, "I haven't seen
that movie in like 10 years,
"but let's do it."
- Is that movie still funny now?
I feel like it's not funny anymore.
- I think it's still funny.
- You think it's funny anymore?
- I didn't find it funny
when it first came out,
I'll be honest.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I don't know, it's a...
- Again, it's like that whole,
like, it's the meta thing.
It's like the fact that Austin Powers
as a character is so-
- It's just like James Bond, right?
- It's just so aware of
what he is that like,
it's the potty humor poopoo peepee humor.
(everyone laughs)
It really is.
- It kind of is.
- I like that humor.
I don't know why I didn't like this movie.
I've seen, sorry, the
"Austin Powers" series,
I think I've seen all of
them and I just thought like,
it's all right.
- It's, I don't know, it's like, for me,
it's just like comfort
food to just go back to.
It's just like, it's either
that or "Bruce Almighty"
in terms of comedy films
where I'm just like, "Yeah,
this is still funny."
- I mean, I think it's just
like the peepee poopoo humor-
- Yeah, I feel like-
- It was a bit too in your face.
- Yeah, when I think of "Austin
Powers," I just feel like,
I like recoil in disgust a little bit.
- I think you know what it is-
- There's so many gross
scenes in that film.
- You know what it is about
"Goldmember" in particular,
I think it's like the
same concept as like,
when you see like, you know,
a troll face comic on Twitter
where it's like it's so not
funny that it's just funny.
- It's just ancient
memes put into a movie.
- This is the second one?
- This the third one.
- Third one.
The one with Fat Bastard.
- Yeah, this is the last one.
- Oh God.
- And like Goldmember is
also played by Mike Myers
where he's like the fucking Dutch guys,
like, "I love gold!"
Like, that character.
It's like, it's so dumb,
that it's like, it's funny.
- I put it in like the same
category as "Scary Movie"
and just, remember "Scary Movie?"
- See, I didn't find
"Scary Movie" funny at all.
- I didn't find it funny at all.
- I think 13-year-old
me loved "Scary Movie."
And then when I watched
it again, I was like, oh.
- It's the same kind of
like hehe peepee poopoo,
this is a parody kind of humor.
And I just like, I never
found that too funny.
I mean, I love peepee poopoo humor jokes,
but it was just a bit too in your face.
Yeah, I don't know.
- Yeah, maybe.
I swear I probably got a few
laughs out of it here and there
but I don't know, maybe.
I don't know why.
- I think I'm kind of just
like numb to comedy movies now
just because the like past five years
of comedy movies have just all
been really fucking mediocre
in my opinion.
- Haven't had many good
comedy movies in a while.
- I'm trying to think of like
the last good comedy movie,
and like, I genuinely-
- "40-Year-Old Virgin."
- I genuinely think it
might be "Goldmember."
Like, I deadass can't
think of comedy movie
that came out after this
that was like nearly as fun.
- Pretty sure "Superbad"
came after this, right?
- As a white guy, I'm
obliged to say "Stepbrothers"
even though I don't really feel that way.
- See, okay.
Hot take, since we're all
doing hot takes on movies.
I don't think I've ever laughed
at a Will Ferrell movie.
- No, I mean-
- There isn't a single Will Ferrell movie-
- I don't actually think
"Stepbrothers" is very good,
I was just joking.
- There's one scene in
"Stepbrothers" that I was like, ha.
- When I was like 15
'cause I think that movie
just came out, 15, 16.
- I'm gonna check Will
Ferrell's entire filmography
to see if I actually agree with that.
- Because like
"Stepbrothers" was like okay.
I thought "Blades of Glory"
was not funny at all.
- They were just like,
they were the most six
to seven out of 10 films.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What's his most...
- Okay, "Anchorman."
- "Anchorman" is just like just driven
to the fucking ground now.
- I don't know if that's just
like had the "Borat" phase-
- Oh, "Elf" was pretty good.
I like "Elf."
- "Elf" is overrated as fuck.
- I think "Elf" is overrated.
- [Connor] I think "Elf" is fun.
- The thing that I don't
understand about "Elf" is
that like it gained like
a cult classic following
after like all this time of being ignored.
- I like "Talladega Nights."
I actually like "Talladega Nights."
'Cause it has Sasha Baron Cohen in it.
- I'm just looking at this
and I'm just like, it's okay.
Everything's okay.
Like, "Anchorman,"
I feel like I've watched "Anchorman"
passed when like it was
already memed to death.
And I feel like the best part
of "Anchorman" was Steve Carell.
- [Joey] Oh yeah.
- Why are late night shows
listed as filmography?
- I don't know.
Yeah, I guess I just
don't find Will Ferrell
that funny I guess.
- "The Lego Movie" is pretty good.
He's in that.
- What?
- "Lego Movie."
Oh, I like-
- Oh no, no, no.
"21 Jump Street," that was
the last great comedy movie.
- Yeah, "21 Jump Street."
- Come on, come on, come on, come on.
- See, I didn't watch it.
- That's actually really good.
- That was the last great comedy movie.
- 'Cause I watched the
original "21 Jump Street."
- No, the new one's really good.
- The one with, what's his face?
- Ice Cube and...
- No, no, no.
The one with,
like the really, really old one with...
Oh, fuck.
Was it "21 Jump Street?"
I might be thinking of something else.
The one with Ice Cube though was okay.
- Who was the main character in that?
- It's Channing Tatum.
- Channing Tatum.
Channing Tatum and...
- Jonah Hill.
Jonah Hill is just an amazing actor.
- Oh yeah, but like,
I prefer Jonah hill in like
the more serious movies though.
- Jonah Hill is so good now.
- As much as I love Jim
Carrey in "Bruce Almighty"
and like all the Jim
Carrey like classic comedy
like "Mask" and "The Grinch" and all that.
I fucking love Jim Carrey
in all the serious roles.
- Yeah, his serious roles are really good.
- The other one I was thinking like,
I'll put "Bruce Almighty" there
just 'cause it's like the
comedy movie I can go back to.
It's like classic.
But like if I didn't put "Bruce Almighty"
or any Jim Carrey comedy, I would've put,
do you know "The Number 23?"
- Oh yeah, yeah.
- That's like really
like kind of neo noire,
like the most serious-
- You like that one?
- I kind of liked it.
(everyone laughs)
I kinda liked it.
It's like that one
or like "Eternal Sunshine
of the Spotless Mind."
- That was good.
- That one's good.
And then another one I saw was-
- "Truman Show" is my
favorite Jim Carrey movie.
Such a fucking good movie.
- Yeah, "Truman Show" is good.
Yeah, I don't know something
about "The Number 23" was like,
it was so fucking edgy
that it just became entertaining again.
You know what I mean?
Where like, it's like a point of edgy-ness
where it's like, it just
all comes back around-
- Wasn't that like destroyed by critics
for like being pretentious?
- It was destroyed.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, look, have you
seen my three by three?
It's pretentious as fuck.
- Joey's like, "Ah,
yes, I don't understand.
"Perfect."
- I think the fact that I
put in a Akira Kurosawa film
goes to show
that I'm a pretty fucking
pretentious movie critic.
- Wow.
- What'd you guys think of,
while we're on the topic of comedy movies,
Seth Rogen films, how
do we feel about that?
- Kind of the same thing I
feel about Will Ferrell movies.
- What was...
- I'm just like-
- "Pineapple Express" is okay.
- It's like ha ha, he smokes weed.
- I feel like, if it's not like purely
just Seth Rogen being a stoner,
then it's a pretty funny film.
- I like Seth Rogen as a person.
(everyone laughs)
I like the stoner actor Seth Rogen,
but like Seth Rogen in films,
I'm just kinda just like, eh.
- I like his movies.
You just turn your brain
off and it's an easy movie.
You know, sometimes it's
just hard movies to watch.
- I can't even think of
like a Seth Rogen movie.
- Like, the Akira Kurosawa
films are not the kind of thing
I can just put on..
- Oh, no, no, no, of course not.
- It's like, you know you always get
just a film you can watch with Seth Rogen.
- Actually, do you wanna know
how fucking pretentious I am
as a film critic?
Instead of "Goldmember,"
I was gonna put "2001: A Space Odyssey."
(everyone laughs)
- I would have actually been like,
"Actually fuck off."
(everyone laughs)
"Actually get the fuck out."
- Joey, who are you trying to please?
Joey, who are you trying to please?
- I'm trying to please myself, all right?
- One thing I'm surprised
that's not on here is "Trainspotting."
'Cause you've talked about that a bunch.
- Fuck.
You know what, I completely
forgot about that.
(everyone laughs)
Actually, yeah, can we
get rid of "Goldmember"
and put "Trainspotting?"
- No, no, no, it's already done.
- Please?
Do me a solid.
No, he did it with the
fucking gaming three by three.
I can do it with the movie.
Okay.
Munon or whoever's editing,
get rid of "Goldmember."
- [Garnt] This is a shit movie anyway.
- [Joey] Get rid of "Goldmember,"
put "Trainspotting" on it.
"Trainspotting" is fucking fantastic.
- Someone criticized me because I said,
when someone, they asked me
what my favorite video game
or whatever was,
I said different from what
I put on my three by three.
We make our three by
threes in like 10 minutes.
It's not like the end all of our actual.
- Exactly, exactly.
- We're just trying to
make some interesting.
Yeah, they're fine.
- I'm thinking,
oh, I've really enjoyed "This is the End,"
a Seth Rogen film.
- "50/50" was really good.
- Oh, "50/50" was great.
- I haven't seen any of these.
(Garnt laughs)
- They're ones where like the joke isn't
just him being a stoner.
And that's why I feel like-
- Wait, is that even possible?
- Yeah, yeah.
Occasionally he does.
- 'Cause I think it with Seth Rogen, like,
I watched one film with Seth
Rogen in it and I was like-
- Was it "Pineapple Express?"
- It might've been.
And I was like, I 100%
understand this actor
and this character now.
Probably like that in every other movie.
- Yeah.
"Pineapple Express" is
one of those movies-
- Oh my God, fucking, can I
talk about "Trainspotting."
- Okay, okay, sorry, sorry.
- It's so good!
Okay, have you guys seen it?
- Of course I have.
- I have not.
- You haven't seen it?
Okay.
So, "Trainspotting" is this like,
oh God, how the fuck do you
explain "Trainspotting?"
- I know that it's not
about spotting trains.
- It is not about spotting trains.
- So, the term trainspotting
comes from heroin addicts
where they try to inject
the heroin into their veins,
so they have to spot the veins
and that is referred to as trainspotting.
- So basically it's a
drug film set in Scotland.
Main guy is Ewan McGregor
who he is in his natural habitat.
He's in his natural accent, so
you know it's gonna be good.
Very, very young Ewan McGregor.
I think this is before "Star Wars."
- I think the one scene I remember
from "Trainspotting" apart
from the baby scene was just-
- The toilet scene.
- Yeah, just Ewan McGregor
emerges from a toilet.
- Yeah, I've heard about this.
I've heard of the scenes
in "Trainspotting."
- So very famous scene is where
Ewan McGregor needs to go,
you know, do a hit,
and he's at a pub and he
goes into the closest,
no, no, that's right.
No, he gets the runs I
think from something.
And he runs into a pub
and goes into probably
the most disgusting
looking toilet imaginable.
- Just UK toilets.
- It's like actually foul.
And he drops his drugs into the toilet.
And because he's a desperate junkie,
and he took a shot beforehand,
he starts hallucinating as
he reaches into the toilet
and just goes into the toilet
and starts swimming inside the toilet.
Emerges out of the toilet
with the drugs in his hand.
It's a very, very bizarre movie.
But I (laughs) I showed
"Trainspotting" to Aki,
and she stopped it after
five minutes and she's like,
"Can we put subtitles on?
"'Cause I can't understand
what the fuck they're saying."
To be fair, it's a very
heavy Scottish accent.
Like, there were some
scenes where even I'm like,
"Oh, I didn't quite catch what
he just fucking said there."
So, like Americans, probably
best to put subtitles on.
- Being from the UK is like
your English level is OP.
You can understand any form of English.
- Any accent.
- The only reason why I
understand "Trainspotting" is
because I like watched
it like over 10 times.
So, I just remember what they say.
But yeah, I don't know,
it's just like, it's very brutal film,
but also it's like, again,
like the music choices-
- [Connor] Sounds good.
- With movies if it's
got great music choice,
I'm all for it.
Same with my anime.
If the OST is good, it's a great movie.
- I'd say if there's like
two, like drug like films,
kind of like, how do I describe this?
- Is that a category?
Drug movie.
- Yeah, drug movies.
- Drug movie.
'Cause like I don't really know how
to describe "Trainspotting."
It's just a movie about a
bunch of characters and-
- I'm already sold on it to be fair.
- Their lives revolve around drugs.
And like "Trainspotting" is one of them.
And the other one is
"Requiem for a Dream,"
which is not a film I think
like people should watch to enjoy.
But I think people should
just watch it at least once
to like realize, wow, I just
never want to try heroin.
That's just a bad thing.
- Well, I mean, "Trainspotting"
was definitely one
where I was like, oh, never
touching that shit in my life.
Fuck that.
- You know, I was 50/50 but.
(everyone laughs)
After watching
"Trainspotting," you know...
- If you ever have a friend who's like,
"Maybe I might try heroin,"
just show them "Trainspotting,"
they'll probably be like,
"Nope, never doing that."
- Or "Requiem for a Dream."
- Or "Requiem for a Dream" as well.
- Oh, I think I just got
full on fucking depression
for a week after watching that film.
- I mean, "Trainspotting"
is definitely another film
that is not watched
for entertainment sake.
Probably more entertaining
than "Requiem for a Dream."
- I would like to say like,
"Trainspotting" isn't a happy movie,
but it's like less bleak
than "Requiem for a Dream."
- There's a lot of great
scenes and it's like,
I don't know, it's just, again,
the acting's really
good and it's just very,
it's a very raw film.
- "Requiem for a Dream" just sounds
like something you'd give an
Oscar to based on the title.
(everyone laughs)
- To be fair there's
some great fucking scenes
in "Requiem for a Dream."
- The title alone you're
like, "Fuck, that's awesome."
- The thing I can say about
"Requiem for a Dream" is
that it's just, it's a
fucking powerful movie.
And it's like, it makes you feel emotions
that is not pleasant feeling,
but it's fucking powerful as shit.
- Speaking of powerful,
should we get onto my list?
(everyone laughs)
- Is it powerful?
Are you gonna live up to that expectation?
- When you see this three by
three, you're gonna think,
"Holy shit."
- Does it have "Space Jam" on it?
'Cause if not-
- It doesn't.
- "Rush Hour 2?"
Come on.
- More powerful than any.
- I'm curious to see what your
Quentin Tarantino pick is.
That's what I'm-
- We're gonna have a toilet break now.
- Needless to say, it's gonna be powerful.
I actually did put "No
Country for Old Men."
- Oh, wow.
- What's interesting was is off-camera-
- This is mine, this is mine.
- Yes, this one.
Off-camera Joey was like, "Put
'No Country for Old Men.'"
- Yo.
Honestly, I was so close to
putting some of these on mine.
- [Connor] I knew you were gonna-
- [Joey] Oh, okay, okay.
- [Garnt] 'Cause I was like,
"Maybe someone else is
gonna put 'Ip Man.'"
But that was so close to coming on mine.
- [Connor] This is a powerful
list I think, gentlemen.
I think you'll agree.
- Okay, you know what?
The only one that I probably
have like a little bit
of qualms with is "Tokyo Drift."
- No!
Absolutely not!
This is a masterpiece of cinema.
- If we're talking about
overrated films, "Tokyo Drift."
- It is not overrated.
Listen, the main actor, you know-
- The entire "Fast and Furious"
franchise is overrated.
There, I said it.
- He's an impeccable character actor,
the main actor of "Tokyo Drift."
- I don't know if you're
being serious or not.
- He enveloped like,
nothing has mimicked living in Japan
quite like "Tokyo Drift."
- You're right, you're right.
- When I went to school in some, you know-
- I love all one Japanese
actors in this movie.
(everyone laughs)
- You know, when I was in school in Japan
with my black friend from America...
(everyone laughs)
- We dreamed of going to Japan one day,
and we were like, "What is
the closest we can get to it?"
- You know, I think-
- I wonder if you know.
- Every single point of
"Tokyo Drift" is a masterclass
in filmmaking, frankly.
From the very start, you know,
in the American high school scene,
it's very, very much like how
it would still be in America.
Naturally I race my cars
and I cause a lot of damage
and don't get arrested and get exiled,
which I don't think is a
punishment that you see.
You know, a lot of movies,
they would just arrest him.
And I think he was really
genius that they gave exile.
- Well, you know, like full speed drifting
through a parking lot,
which is just, you know,
if you've ever been to a
parking lot in any country it's
just impossible.
- I think there's not
enough movies that use exile
as a good way of conveying the story.
Name a movie with exile in it.
I'll wait.
There we go.
- Probably for good reason.
- It's a medieval concept
that hasn't been introduced
in modern films, you know?
- Exile.
- Exile, he was exiled
from Arkansas or something.
I don't know where the fuck he was found.
- I don't know.
- Some hick town.
And you know, his accent is just amazing.
I love it.
I love this guy's accent.
So, so much.
I love the accent.
- I don't think I've
ever felt physical pain
while watching a movie before
until I watched "Tokyo Drift."
- I'm gonna be honest,
I have not seen a single
"Fast and Furious" film.
- I've only seen "Tokyo Drift"
and I, you know, because I
didn't want to be annoyed
because we'd already found the
best "Fast and Furious" film
so why watch another one?
- Garnt, I must say, you are
not missing out on anything.
- No, no, "Tokyo Drift."
Have you watched "Tokyo Drift?"
- I literally just said five seconds ago,
I've not seen-
- He's never seen it!
- Literally five seconds ago.
- I don't count it as a
"Fast and Furious" film.
- No, I don't count this
as "Fast and Furious" film.
- It's a cinema experience.
It's a totally different-
- But somehow worse.
- No, it's,
if you add up all the IMDb scores
of the "Fast and Furious" films,
it's still not as high as "Tokyo Drift."
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah, because it's
like zero, zero, zero.
(everyone laughs)
Zero plus zero is still zero.
- "Tokyo Drift" is a great film
that is close to my heart in many ways.
Not only did it get me into-
- Japan?
- Donkey Kong because of the DK.
- Oh yeah, of course.
What's DK stand for?
(everyone laughs)
- That compelled me to
check out Donkey Kong.
- The beginning of monkey.
(everyone laughs)
- Is "Tokyo Drift."
- This was actually-
- This is the monkey origin story.
- You know, it's almost, it's just,
there's nothing quite as
groundbreaking as this film,
quite frankly.
- So what's your favorite scene?
- I like the scene
where he breaks his iPod
and then he still manages
to sell the iPod broken
and then he doesn't check to,
he doesn't check the
iPod before buying it.
I believe this is what happens.
And then he purchased the
iPod then gets annoyed
that it was broken.
But he never once thought,
"I should check this
iPod before buying it."
- Classic storytelling.
- I thought that was a
really intelligent scene
because that's how they made
conflict through a broken iPod.
- What I want to know is
how are there so many "Fast
and the Furious" films?
- Well, this actually saved
the "Fast and Furious" franchise.
- Did it actually?
- No, I don't know.
- I think it deadass
might've 'cause it's like-
- This was the first-
- When you hear of someone
saying "Fast and Furious-"
- I think of "Tokyo Drift."
- Yeah, right.
Most people I think
think of "Tokyo Drift,"
and I'm like, why?
- Like, do the other
"Fast and Furious" films
even have names?
- No, it's like "Fast
and Furious 1, 2, 3, 4"
- Memes aside, how does such
a shit film become so iconic?
Like, that's what I want to know.
It is terrible by every single
metric of the English word.
But I love this film to death.
- It's like "The Room," right?
- It's like "The Room"
of "Fast and Furious."
(Joey laughs)
- "The Room" of "Fast and Furious."
- Because it's just got the coolest name.
I mean, "Tokyo Drift," right?
It's a fucking cool ass name.
- Also, legit, I know we
spoke about it before,
but like it was kind of like
a gateway for me to Japan.
Like, it-
- Was it actually?
- It kind of legit got me
into Japan in many ways.
- I'm sorry.
(Garnt laughs)
- It's great 'cause then I
got to learn actual shit.
Also it was the very
first DVD I ever owned,
was "Tokyo Drift."
And it's in a glass
cabinet as you can imagine.
Vacuum sealed.
- Mint condition.
- Yeah, mint condition.
Had been graded obviously.
- I think the first DVD
I ever owned was "Shrek."
- Well-
- Honestly.
- Okay, so "Tokyo Drift" is
a terrible but amazing movie,
and I can watch it and enjoy it
because you can just laugh at it now.
It's amazing to laugh at.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- Some of the dialogue
that the poor actors have
to actually like say is just hilarious.
And then it gets just not
fun at all towards the end.
And then it becomes too serious.
- Then it becomes too serious.
- So let me ask you one thing.
- [Connor] All right.
- Why "Shrek 2" over "Shrek 1?"
- "Shrek 2" is the best "Shrek."
"Shrek 2" is the best.
- Really?
- It is.
- Dude, "Shrek 2" is the best.
Bro, "Shrek 2" is the best!
- Like, "Shrek" run, set the rules.
- Run?
What is wrong today with your English?
- "Shrek 1" set the rules,
and then "Shrek 2" perfected everything.
- I'm not gonna go against the fact
that "Shrek 2" is a good movie.
- "Shrek 2" is the best, bro.
Prince Charming is fucking amazing.
- I still think "Shrek 1" is better.
- "Shrek 1" is just an
encapsulated experience
that is fantastic.
- I think the problem with "Shrek 1" is
that no one can watch it seriously anymore
because it's been memed
to the ends of the earth.
Not enough scenes in
"Shrek 2" have been memed,
and I think that's why.
- I actually disagree 'cause
I feel like "Shrek" is one
of the few franchises where
the memes have only like put it
into legendary status.
I am never going to
forget "Shrek" anymore.
- Yeah, I can't.
- Like, Smash Mouth can like retire
because they've already been immortalized
through "Shrek" memes.
- "Shrek" is an amazing film
that you can watch any time.
But I think people forget how
fucking amazing "Shrek 2" is.
"Shrek 2" is-
- No, "Shrek 2" is a great film,
I don't disagree with that.
- Honestly, so much better than "Shrek 1".
Watch it.
- In my opinion, like,
"Shrek 1" just inches past.
- "Shrek" is an 8.5 and
"Shrek" is a 9.2 in my head,
"Shrek 2" sorry, is a 9.5.
And "Shrek 1" is a 8.5.
- What about "Shrek the Third?"
- Every single character they, oh, two.
It's not even worth watching.
Every single character they introduce
in "Shrek 2" is a banger character.
They all like help the story so much.
And then they build on the
one-off characters in "Shrek 1"
that you thought were a joke.
They bring them back.
They're like, hold up, hold up.
You know, there's a reason why
the Wolf was cross-dressing.
Let's find out.
- You're gonna see Gingerbread
Man and Pinocchio again.
- Also they use the soundtrack
in very intelligent ways,
you know.
- They do, they do.
- The soundtrack's banging.
- That is true, that is true.
- The rendition of "I Need a
Hero" was like fucking amazing!
- So good!
- It is an amazing scene.
- Puss in Boots is introduced.
- I completely forgot that.
Puss in Boots wasn't in "Shrek 1," was he?
- Yeah, his standalone movie was terrible.
But there's a reason
why he was so lovable.
- It's also amazing to think
like how many fucking high
profile actors are in "Shrek 2."
- Honestly.
- Isn't the Fairy Godmother
played by Julie Andrews?
- I think so.
- I think, yeah.
- If you want your career
made, you're in "Shrek 2."
Coincidence that every
single "Shrek 2" actor
is a god tier actor-
- Yeah, Antonio Banderas
was the cat, right?
- Exactly, man.
- Why did Mike Myers do another
like fucking "Austin Powers"
film when he was in "Shrek?"
Why even try?
Why, Joey?
- I mean, that's because-
- This is the best of Mike Myers film.
- No, I'm not saying "Austin Powers" is
the best Mike Myers film.
"Shrek" 100%.
- 'Cause Mike Myers has
like two good films,
and it's "Shrek,"
one and two.
- "Shrek" and "Shrek 2."
- "Wayne's World" is overrated.
"Shrek 1" and "2" are his only good roles.
- I'll agree "Wayne's
World" is overrated now.
Okay, but let's talk
about the Quentin
Tarantino choice you put?
- Yes.
- "Kill Bill."
- I think-
- Volume one?
- Okay, I like volume one.
- Really?
- I actually-
- For number one?
- I actually prefer volume one.
- Really?
- Volume two is rated higher,
and it's a crime we
didn't get another one.
That's a legit crime we
didn't get a volume three.
- I just think...
I think in the entire filmography
of Quentin Tarantino films,
"Kill Bill" is just
one that I just forget.
- See, the thing for me is
like "Pulp Fiction" isn't
even like my top five
Quentin Tarantino films.
- [Joey] Really?
- Yeah, I think that like
"Inglourious Basterds,"
"Django" is better.
- "Django" is not better.
- "Django" is better.
"Django" is better!
What do you mean?
"Django" is amazing!
- I'll agree, "Inglourious
Basterds" is up there.
"Django" though is not up there.
- "Django" and "Inglourious
Basterds" are both better
than "Pulp Fiction."
- No.
- And "Kill Bill" is
better than "Pulp Fiction."
And what else has he done that's better?
- What about like "Jackie Brown?"
- Look, look, look.
Maybe "Django" would have been
like one of his best films
if not for Jamie Foxx.
I feel like Jamie Foxx was so fucking dry.
- Do you know who was originally cast?
Will Smith.
- Will Smith!
- If they got Will Smith for that movie,
legendary!
- Holy shit!
- He wouldn't have said half the shit.
- Will Smith would have
carried that movie.
- Yeah.
- But because they got Jamie Foxx,
Christoph Waltz had to do the fucking-
- No, no, exactly.
It's Christoph Waltz
and Leonardo DiCaprio.
- I think Jamie Foxx
was great in that movie.
- What do you remember after
the big scene in the middle?
- I think I actually can't remember much.
- That's the point!
Because-
- It's been so long since I've watched.
- Because after that it's Jamie Foxx
who has to carry the
film and he just doesn't.
He doesn't.
- Jamie Foxx tries
when fucking decrepit
Samuel L. Jackson walks off.
- I was gonna say like,
actually like, you know, everyone
focusing Christoph Waltz,
and he did amazing and
so did Leonardo DiCaprio,
but like Samuel L. Jackson is
like probably one of my
favorite things in that film.
He is so fucking good at being evil.
- He's good, he's good.
Don't get me wrong.
But it's not the best
Samuel L. Jackson role in-
- It's because every single
fucking role he does is amazing.
Like, Samuel L. Jackson
kills it in everything.
- Yeah, I get that, but
like, I think his roll
in like "Jackie Brown"
was 100 times better.
- I just, I don't know.
- I had more fun watching
like "Jackie Brown'
and like even "Kill Bill" over "Django."
- I just, I don't think
"Pulp Fiction" was that good.
- How dare you.
(Joey laughs)
- Wow.
- I think it was fine.
There was just like,
there was too many scenes
where I was actually bored
during "Pulp Fiction."
- What?
- Like, the scene where
they're at the restaurant
just talking, I was bored out of my mind.
- What, do you mean the one at the end?
- No, no, the start, the start.
Not the diner, the restaurant
where they're like,
were they having like
milkshakes with John Travolta.
- Oh, at Jack Rabbits.
- Yeah, I can't fucking stand it.
- That scene's fucking great.
- I just think John Travolta
is like not a good actor.
I think he's not good.
- I mean, I don't know-
- What are these takes, dude?
- John Travolta is a bad actor.
- No, no, no, okay.
- John Travolta is very much-
- Samuel L. Jackson carries,
it's so obvious because
when Samuel L. Jackson isn't
with John Travolta, John Travolta sucks.
- Okay, in my opinion, John-
- How many scenes were there
without those two together?
There wasn't many.
It was a duo.
- Like one or two,
and he was terrible.
- I think John Travolta is-
- Not terrible but.
- John Travolta is one of those actors
where like I feel-
- Have you seen his recent movies?
- No, but that's because,
okay, recent John Travolta
movies he's clearly like,
has just been type casted as the bad guy
because of "Pulp Fiction."
Because before "Pulp Fiction,"
John Travolta just did all
the "Grease" lightning movies.
So he literally went-
- Oh yeah, he was in "Grease."
- He literally went from
this like sing songy,
like cool, cool boy guy
to suddenly playing as
this like badass gangster.
And because of the
success of "Pulp Fiction,"
the movie industry was
like, "We need a bad guy
"who's also like kind of quirky
and charming on the surface
"but is actually fucked up on the inside.
"John Travolta."
- I mean, like, "Pulp Fiction" isn't
my favorite Tarantino film.
- What's your favorite one?
- I mean, I put it on.
It's "Reservoir Dogs."
- Oh.
- Like, I still would put like,
I really love "Inglourious Basterds."
- Yeah.
Would you say "Inglourious
Basterds" is better
than "Pulp Fiction" to you?
- I'd say it's about the same.
- I think "Inglourious Basterds" is good.
It's better than "Pulp Fiction"
but for different reasons.
- I do agree with you
where there are some parts
of "Pulp Fiction" that did drag.
But when, like, I feel like
the highs of "Pulp Fiction" are
just they're like the
best Tarantino can do.
"Kill Bill" is I feel like one of his most
different movies.
- I love "Kill Bill."
- "Kill Bill" is clearly the
movie where Tarantino was like,
"I like anime by the way."
(everyone laughs)
- I love it.
- "I really like anime.
"I really like Japan."
- It's so cool.
I just love it.
Everything about the movie is just so fun.
- No, I mean, like Uma
Thurman is fucking awesome.
- I love Uma Thurman.
- I love the scene with, what's her name?
Kuriyama Chiaki who did Gogo Yubari
with like the chain thing.
- That's so good!
I love that!
- I just love fucking Uma
Thurman's janky Japanese
when like Gogo Yubari comes
out like swinging the chain
and then Uma Thurman
turns around, she's like,
"Gogo danay?"
(everyone laughs)
That scene fucking kills me every time.
- Yeah. I mean, I feel
like on an aesthetic level,
there's few that are as
iconic as "Kill Bill."
- It's just such a fucking,
and also the restaurant is
still like open in Tokyo.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, going there and
like seeing it and be like,
"Fuck."
It's so cool.
When you go to that restaurant,
you're like, "Fuck, how
did they make this happen?"
- It's definitely like a
culturally significant movie.
- I mean, for the record,
all of Quentin Tarantino
movies are fucking amazing.
I just feel like "Kill Bill"
is like the most different,
I feel like, especially in
terms of Tarantino movies.
Volume two felt way more
like a Tarantino movie.
- I deadass don't even remember
what happens in volume two.
- She fucking kills Bill, Joey.
(everyone laughs)
Joey!
- How dare you spoil!
- Joey!
- I can't believe you spoiled "Kill Bill."
- It's literally there in the title.
- I've rewatched the
first one so many times
I've barely watched the second one.
I don't know why.
- I don't know, it's just like,
I've definitely seen "Kill Bill
Volume 2" a couple of times.
I just don't remember what happened
other than the titular thing.
- I would say that the only film,
I mean, the only scene out of "Kill Bill"
that really sticks out
to my mind is the one
at the end of "Kill Bill Volume 1"
which is her against...
- Lucy Liu, right?
- Lucy Liu.
- No, not Lucy Liu.
The one with her against like the fucking,
what, the name of the
gang that she fights?
- That's not the end.
- The Crazy 88s.
- Yeah, that's like in the middle.
- No, that's like right before the end.
- No, right before the end
is when she fights Lucy Liu.
- Yeah, that's the ending.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, so the one, so,
she fights the Crazy 88
before she fights Lucy Liu.
To me, that is like the iconic scene
of the "Kill Bill" franchise.
- It's fucking awesome.
- But I felt like overall,
I felt like the second film
was just a little bit better.
- I have to rewatch it honestly.
- I have to, I think-
- Why is this your favorite
Tarantino movie then?
- I don't know.
Again, I think it's just how unique it is
and how stylized.
Like, you don't really get
a movie like it any more.
I don't know.
- Yeah, definitely not anymore.
- It's just such a good movie.
- I feel this is the only successful
live-action anime adaptation.
You know what I mean?
Where it's like,
this feels like it was based off of anime.
- It had actual fucking anime in it.
- Oh yeah, it's got a production IG.
That's fucking badass.
- That scene was dope.
- The whole lore when they build it up.
Oh my God, it's just so fucking cool.
I love everything about that film.
It's just like him just like saying,
"Hey guys, I'm a weeb."
And like you said, but in a good way,
in a way that you're like, okay.
- It's definitely done from
like a place of like respect.
- It's just, like, you watch this
and you just feel like this is just fun.
This is just a director
having fucking fun.
- It's definitely the most
like turn your brain off type
of Tarantino film.
- It's the best kind.
- [Joey] No, absolutely.
- Because you don't need
to turn your brain off
to appreciate this movie.
But at the same time,
it follows that kind of same style
where you don't have to think much,
but everything about this just has impact.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Impact.
- I definitely agree "Kill Bill' is good.
I just want to rewatch it now.
It's been awhile.
- What do you wanna talk about next, boys?
- Honestly, honestly,
I know you put this on because you thought
that I was gonna like, just
fucking destroy you for it,
but I'm glad someone put an
Adam Sandler movie on here.
- Listen, "Click," I love "Click."
- Okay, 100% easily the
best Adam Sandler film.
- Okay, okay.
Well, a film made by Adam,
this is made by him, right?
- I think so, yeah.
- Dude, "Click" is so good.
- "Click" is a really good movie.
- I still cry at the end of "Click"
every single God damn time.
- Actually, I was like-
- "Family comes first."
(everyone laughs)
That's all I can remember.
- I was really, really close
to putting "50 First Dates"
on my three by three.
(everyone laughs)
- No!
No "Click" is actually good.
- "Click" is really good.
- "Click" is good.
- "Click" is one of those movies
that gets so much bad rep,
but like I actually think it's like,
come on, it's pretty fucking-
- Adam Sandler has a bad rep.
- . Of course, there's some
scenes in there you're like,
"All right, Adam, come on."
But then there's also so
many moments you're like,
"Holy shit, this is actually
like a really good fucking take
"on your life and missing out on things."
- Especially the second
half where it starts
to get really serious.
I'm just like, oh my God,
this is not the direction
I was expecting it to go.
- It's so good.
It shows that like when Adam
Sandler wants to fucking act,
he brings his fucking A-game.
- I was like, "Wow, he can act?"
- Again, this is like, why
watching "Uncut Gems" is like,
all the shit parts of
"Click" are like not there,
just great fucking
acting from Adam Sandler.
And like, it's amazing.
- I just feel like people
forget that I think Adam Sandler
actually made good films.
I like a lot of-
- Just lazy.
- I feel like "Click" might
be his like last great film
or last good film
'cause I remember like he
just like fell off a cliff
after a certain point but-
- Now he just makes,
he's openly admitted
that he makes movies on,
basically if he can go to
a vacation on the place,
'cause it's his production company.
- What a power move.
- The movies that he makes,
it's his production company.
So he just picks places
he can go on vacation
with his family.
- I think there's a lot of
good Adam Sandler movies
that I've really enjoyed.
Like, has anyone seen "Anger Management?"
- Yeah, yeah.
- I really, really enjoyed.
Jack Nicholson and Adam Sandler,
my God, that's such a good film.
He has such a bad rep, but I fucking,
like his films defined a lot of
like the early 2000s comedies I feel.
Nothing wrong with "Click."
- Yeah, nothing wrong with "Click."
Easily, I mean, fucking what's
his name, as well is in it.
Christopher Walken.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's the one that gives the remote, right?
- Yeah, he's the one
that gives the remote.
- I just wish they didn't
set it up so fucking stupid.
Like, in a Bed Bath Beyond he gets it.
- He's like, yeah, he's
like a security guard
at Bed Bath and Beyond.
- And there's so many
fucking childish jokes,
like when he farts on the guy and stuff
and then fast forwards in the room.
Like, that shit's so dumb
'cause like they actually hit
so many good fucking emotional notes.
I wish they didn't fucking
sully it with that shit.
But it's actually a good movie.
I love it.
It's so good.
- Although to be fair,
the scene where he like
smacks the boss in the face
and then plays it, and goes like,
"Whoa, I just had a massive headache."
That scene is still really funny.
- Yeah, yeah, there's some good moments.
- Okay.
I have never seen "Catch Me If You Can."
- You haven't?
- [Joey] No.
- It's so good!
- It's a movie I've heard so many times.
- I think it is the best
Leonardo DiCaprio film.
- That's all I've heard from people.
- And then there's Tom
Hanks in it as well.
And Tom Hanks is just a fucking delight.
- I mean, I feel like it's...
- What do you think is,
when you think Leonardo DiCaprio,
what movie comes to your mind?
- I don't think of "Catch Me If You Can."
I think of Tom Hanks for this one.
- I don't think of him for it.
But then also when I think of it,
it uses like everything
that Leonardo DiCaprio,
especially at that point in his life-
- What movie do you think of
when you say Leonardo DiCaprio now?
- Probably now "Wolf of Wall Street."
- Yeah, I think "Wolf of Wall Street."
- That's because-
- Oh, really?
I think of "Shutter Island."
- Really?
- What?
- I just really like that movie.
- Okay, that's a good movie.
- It's either "Wolf of
Wall Street' or "Django."
- I feel like Leonardo DiCaprio
has evolved quite a lot
during his time because
he's been acting since like-
- Remember when he was the "Titanic" boy?
Nobody knew him for
anything else but "Titanic."
- But like, I feel like
when he did this movie,
it like perfectly captured at that age
what he was best at doing,
was playing like the sexy young guy.
And he's so fucking good in this movie.
And I love it.
- I mean, he's good in every movie.
- You need to watch this movie.
- No, no, I do.
And this is one of those movies
that I've heard people
talking about for years now,
and I just never found
the time to watch it.
- And it's based on a true story.
And like the guy-
- It's a biopic?
- It is a biopic.
- I love biopics.
- The guy who it's
actually based on has done
like Google talks now about how he,
I think he's done work.
He did like work for the
FBI afterwards and stuff.
- I think he was in this movie
or at least he was a producer.
- Yeah, because I've
purposely like not looked
into this film 'cause I
feel like I just want to go
into it blind.
- Yeah, just watch it.
It's such a good story.
And although obviously it's dramatized,
it is based on a real
event, and it's so good.
- 'Cause like if I was to
actually do a three by three
with like my top favorite
movies of all time,
there would definitely also
be a Tom Hanks movie in there.
- Oh dude, "Castaway"
would be in here for me.
- I had only seen "Castaway" recently,
and it was one of the few movies that-
- You only saw it recently?
- Yeah, I only saw it recently.
But it was one of the few movies
where despite how much
hype had gone into it,
I thought it was as good.
It lived up to everything.
I thought it was an amazing fucking film.
- "Catch Me If You Can" is more
of a Leonardo DiCaprio film
than a Tom Hanks film.
- I feel like it's half and half.
To me-
- It's two big names.
- It's two very big
names, and I feel like,
yeah, it is Leonardo DiCaprio.
He does do really well in it.
And I feel like he
just, him and Tom Hanks,
it's both of them in that film.
Whereas with "Castaways" Tom Hanks,
and what was the other fucking
massive Tom Hanks film that-
- "Green Mile?"
- Not "Green Mile."
- Was he in "Green Mile?"
- Yeah, he plays the main security guard.
- Oh yeah.
- "Forrest Gump."
Fucking what an amazing film.
That will probably be like in my-
- Also "Saving Private Ryan" as well.
- Everything he's in he's good.
- "Toy Story."
Hello?
- Oh yeah.
- Anything that man is in
is a good film, straight up.
- I just feel like he's the world's dad.
I don't know.
(Joey laughs)
- He's everyone's dad.
- He is everyone's dad.
I want Tom Hanks as a dad.
Are you fucking kidding me?
My God.
- I feel like we should
explain some of the plots
of these.
"Catch Me If You Can-"
- I just feel these are
such like big movies
that everyone should know them.
- "Catch Me If You Can"
if you haven't seen it,
it's about a guy who pretends
to be a pilot and that's it.
That's literally it.
And about a detective trying to find him.
- That's not what it's about.
- It's kind of it.
I don't want to spoil too much!
- Yeah, don't go too into detail.
- I don't want to give
more information than that.
- I just know it's a fucking amazing film,
and I need to watch it.
- That's like, I mean,
it's that, but it's not,
but just watch it.
Like, that's it, kind of.
(Garnt laughs)
- That's like saying like,
"Sixth Sense" is about a divorce.
- I mean, it's the real life
story of a con artist, right?
That's pretty much it.
- Okay, and then, okay.
I appreciate the fact
that you put "Willy Wonka
and the Chocolate Factory"
but the OG one.
- Yeah, the OG one.
The new one sucked.
- Yeah, the new one sucks.
- I think it's got its
50th anniversary this year.
- Damn, already?
- Yeah.
- Shit.
- I just love this movie.
I can watch like as,
from a young age to now,
like fucking Gene Wilder is
like such a God damn good actor.
Holy shit, this movie's good.
- I mean, it's-
- Also fuck his granddad, bro.
Fuck his granddad.
- I mean, it's a classic
movie for a reason, right?
I mean, already mentioned "The
Truman Show" as well, which-
- Great movie.
- Was my favorite Jim
Carrey movie as well.
Why are there so many,
like why are so many comedy actors
that are just like actual, just
really fucking good actors?
- I think you need to understand
emotions well to be funny,
I think.
- Jim Carrey is such a fucking good actor
when he decides to act.
- I feel sorry for that, man.
He seems like he has a lot of problems.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I feel like comedy
actors normally do have
that problem.
- I really want to rewatch
"The Truman Show" now
because I want to,
because the entire premise
of "The Truman Show" is
that it's just, is it a twist?
Can I spoil it?
- I think everyone knows what it is.
If you don't know what the twist is,
you should know what the twist is.
- So, it follows the story of this guy
whose entire life has
just been broadcasted.
It's just like, it's just his
life is a reality TV show.
- They've made a world around
this man to make a TV show.
- This was a "Black Mirror" episode
before "Black Mirror" was a thing.
- Basically.
- This is basically just IRL Twitch,
before IRL Twitch was a thing.
And now it is a thing.
- Except that in the movie,
he doesn't want to be filmed.
IRL Twitch people are
like, "Yeah, let's do it."
- Okay, so you remember
Ludwig's sub-athon?
Just imagine that from like birth.
- But he didn't know.
And that's "The Truman Show"
and it's just a fucking amazing film.
- I'd love to see "The Truman Show,"
except where Truman is
just a horrible person
because Truman in this is a nice guy.
What if Truman did things
that got him canceled all the time?
You know?
Would people still watch the show?
Would the ratings go down?
How would they fix the ratings
if Truman was going around-
- Just gets canceled.
- Just getting canceled.
They're like, "Fuck, we gotta interfere.
"We gotta reeducate Truman."
- [Joey] And then we joked
about "No Country for Old Men."
- [Connor] Yeah, I fucking love this film.
- It's a great film.
It's just one of those films that's like,
"Yes, I'm a movie critic."
- I don't think that based on my list
that you could say that about me.
But I do think that "No
Country for Old Men" was
the first film where I was like,
"Wait, you can just like
make things this ambiguous?
"What the fuck?
"What the fuck?"
And it's also not cheesy as fuck.
- I mean, I do like my very
kind of open-ended ambiguous films.
"Memento" was one of them.
- You know, you don't really have a film
where you follow the main character often
that acts, behaves in this cold way
that you're also like, you're like,
"Come on, tell me something."
And they just don't tell you anything.
- I think the only other film
that's even remotely like that is maybe
like "American Psycho."
- Maybe, yeah.
But every single, like,
you know, when you rewatch
this movie so many times,
and then you go and watch like-
- Have you rewatched it a lot?
- Yeah, 'cause it used
to be on channel four
all the fucking time.
- Yeah, it did, didn't it?
- So I used to watch it
all the fucking time,
like 10 ad breaks in between.
But like, you know, you'd watch this movie
and then you'd read about
it and you'd be like,
"Oh, that's what that was about."
And then you go back and watch it.
"Oh shit!"
- I was exactly the same with,
and I was debating whether to put it on,
but I was like, no, my three by three is
already pretentious enough.
I was gonna put "Mulholland Drive."
- Oh my God.
- Oh my fucking...
Great film by the way.
- Great film.
David Lynch is one of
my favorite directors.
But I was like, I don't want
this to be more pretentious.
- That's what I was thinking as well.
- There's so many things
in "No Country for Old Men"
that I just love so much to this day.
Like, the fact that he
just decides sometimes
to flip a coin to kill them.
And he went through with it.
Like, if it genuinely went heads,
he wouldn't like it would kill them.
And it's like, holy
shit, this man is insane.
- Yeah, like, I've gone through
this like recent phase of
just like instead of
watching movies again,
I just rewatch clips from movies.
And for some reason, like,
because I watched one,
another iconic clip gets recommended,
and like, I remember just
rewatching the gas station scene-
- I fucking love that!
- And holy fuck.
What a good scene.
I think out of like the
entire history of movies,
in terms of like tension,
I can't think of a better scene than that.
- He's just such a good actor as well,
but I can't remember the main man.
He was one of the villains
in the "Bond" movies.
But he's terrifying.
He's so good at this.
- Those eyes, man.
- I know, right?
- Cold blooded eyes.
- Every single dialogue moment
that he has with anyone,
it's just like, oh my God,
it's fucking terrifying.
- That's funny you say you go back
and like watch movie clips
of like iconic movies
'cause I have that exact thing
with the fucking court scene
in "There Will Be Blood."
(Garnt laughs)
Like, Daniel Day Lewis is like doing
that like insane monologue
at the courtroom,
and I'm like, holy shit.
I need to go back and watch this movie,
but I can't be fucked to
go back and watch this.
- I actually like (laughs) there's,
there's been the phase now where,
because I've been watching
a lot of movie clips,
sometimes I just watch clips
from movies I haven't seen.
And then I end up just-
- You psychopath.
- Huh?
- No, because like it gets recommended
and like it's a good clickbait title.
I'm like, damn, that was a good scene.
And then I watch another
clip and another clip.
And I feel like there's a
lot of people doing this now
because I go to the comments section,
and,
- Psychopath.
- I go to the comments
section and it's just like,
I feel like it's people
who've gone through the exact
same algorithm journey as me.
'Cause I remember going
through the comments section
and it's just,
"I feel like I've watched
this entire movie now
"just through clips."
And I'm just like, that's
exactly what I did!
- Those poor cinema directors
pour their heart out
to make a cohesive
story that's well paced,
and you motherfuckers go
on YouTube and watch clips.
"I've seen the movie now.
"I've seen four clips."
- "I've seen the TikTok clips of it."
- Oh my God.
Yeah, I fucking love that movie.
I can rewatch it as many times.
- Yeah, I mean, watch
"No Country for Old Men."
It's a very good film.
- That's a great film.
- Or just watch the gas
station scene on YouTube.
- No!
Don't do that!
- With zero context.
- You need to watch the whole film!
- And be very confused why this
guy is asking this other guy
to flip a coin.
- It's still a great
scene even out of context.
- The fucking dialogue
he asks people is, like,
the things he asks people are so creepy.
- The thing that stands out to me
in that film wasn't the dialogue,
but it's when he puts
down the candy wrapper
and it just like expands for
like a little bit too long.
And I've never been so tense hearing
just a candy wrapper expand.
I'm just like, what the fuck?
- Also, the coolest weapon
ever used in a movie.
- Yeah.
- The fucking gas canister.
So fucking cool.
Because you're like, oh, this is badass
but fuck he's terrifying.
But man, that's cool though.
- Really scary.
I forgot Tommy Lee Jones
is in that movie as well.
- Yeah, he's the main guy
trying to get him, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
The detective or police guy or whatever.
- The sheriff.
- The sheriff, that's right, yeah.
- And then of course, last
of all, we've got "Ip Man."
Fucking...
I mean, what can you say?
- It's the best, one of the best,
if not the best martial arts movie,
especially in the past 20 years.
- I agree with that.
- There's a lot of, I mean,
I'm sure a lot of people who
are massive martial arts buff
would argue there's a
lot of the earlier films,
like some of Jet Li's earlier stuffs,
some of Jackie Chan's earlier stuff.
- What happened to Jet Li?
He just kinda disappeared.
- He kind of jetted.
- As far as I know-
(everyone laughs)
- Get the fuck out of here.
- So as far as I know what
happened with Jet Li is
that after "Fearless," which was the 2008-
- Which I thought was
a fucking amazing film.
- It was supposed to be his last,
that was supposed to be his last
like epic martial arts film.
And it was kind of well received.
It was, it's like a very
seven, six out of 10 film.
- I thought it was really good.
It was, actually like,
I think it's really
underrated for a Jet Li movie.
- I mean, his older
stuff is just way better.
- Yeah, I know.
But in terms of modern stuff.
- You know, and that was
supposed to be his last one.
And then what ended up happening was is
that the "Expendables" were like money.
So that was actually like-
- That's right, he was
in "The Expendables."
- So that was like his last action film.
And since then, he kind of said,
as far as I know, he kind of quit doing
big martial arts films 'cause
I think it's just too intense.
Like, it's a lot 'cause you have to,
those scenes, like choreograph is insane.
- I just remembered the
fucking "Expendables" movie.
I was like talk about
the most wankerish movie.
Like, "Let's just get as
many big people as possible
"and just throw them into a movie."
- It's just fun, right?
- It was fun.
- But have you seen this?
- I've seen "Ip Man," yeah.
- When did you watch "Ip Man?"
- I actually watched it not too long ago
'cause you recommended it.
- Did you like it?
- Yeah, it's really fucking good.
I mean, I love Jet Li.
- It's got one of my favorite
fight scenes is when he,
fighting the Japanese and
the karate, like 10 of them
and he breaks their leg.
- That scene I think is like the best,
one of the best fucking martial
arts scenes of all time.
Talking about clips you
can rewatch on YouTube.
- Yeah, okay, to be fair,
all right, yeah, that's fair enough.
- You can watch Kung Fu fights.
But like you can't watch that scene
from "No Country for
Old Men" out of context.
(everyone laughs)
- It's just, like the story of "Ip Man"
is it's about when Japan
is invading China way back.
And then I think there's a scene where,
but once they've invaded they're like,
oh well, you know,
"Japanese karate or something is superior.
"So bring your Chinese
people to practice with."
- To practice.
- That's literally what it is.
It's like, if you win, you get
a bag of rice or something.
And he's like, "I'll take on 10 of you."
Okay, it's kind of cheesy, but it is epic.
But it's so fucking epic.
And he like snaps their legs doing it.
It's insane.
- I feel that kind of cheesiness though
in martial arts films is what
makes a martial arts film.
- It totally is.
I feel like it set, that scene alone,
it set the stakes perfectly
where it's just like,
holy shit, I'm ready to
see him fuck shit up.
And he just takes on 10 black belts.
- That's not even like the
end of the film though.
It's like halfway through.
But it's the best fight.
- It's the best fight of the franchise.
'Cause I remember when,
because the previous guy,
he fought like three black belts,
and he's like, "Fuck,
I'll take on all of you."
And it's just one of
the few moments in film
where you're just like,
'I'm ready for this."
- You don't care how cheesy it is.
- Yeah, I don't care how cheesy this is.
- Especially like when you are like,
so when I was like 16,
whenever I was watching all these movies,
I legitimately thought like
martial arts is like badass
and I'm like, dude, this is epic.
But obviously now with all the, you know,
the MMA fighters that like fought them,
now it's not so epic
because you're like, okay,
the MMA fighters just kill these guys.
But when you're like 16, you think like,
"Oh shit, this is like the
superior way of fighting.
"This is epic.
"Oh my God!"
Like, it's so cool.
- "They don't use strength,
they use speed and balance!"
- It's so fucking cool.
But yeah, now, not so much.
But back then, you're like,
"Oh my God, this is amazing!"
There's a lot of martial,
like Jet Li's earlier stuff is amazing.
Obviously Jackie Chan's
earlier cinemography is amazing
as well.
Love like "Drunken Master"
and stuff like that.
That's such a good film.
What are some really good,
what's the, I forgot
what Jet Li's highest
rated film is called.
It's his 1980s film.
It's really highly rated.
Is it "Fist of the Dragon" is it?
Or "Enter the Dragon" or something?
- "Enter the Dragon" is a Bruce Lee movie.
- [Ashley] "Fist of the Legend."
- "Fist of the Legend" that's it.
That's like, his,
like I think it has like
100% on Rotten Tomatoes.
- I was about to say "Fist of Fury,"
but I'm pretty sure
that's Bruce Lee, right?
- That's Bruce Lee.
- Also "Hero" with Jet
Li is a really good one.
But it depends if you'd
like martial arts film
where they use like wires.
Like, some people don't
like it when they do that.
- It's wire fu, right?
- I kind of prefer it when they're just
like beating the shit out of each other.
- Is that the name of the genre?
Wire fu?
- I know it has a name.
- [Ashley] It's called wirework.
- Wirework.
- It's not really martial
arts, but it is martial arts.
But "Hero" was really good.
2006.
- I really liked "Hero" which
had Donnie Yen in it as well.
And Jet Li.
- The story's so fucking cool.
- Yeah, I think that story is cool.
- I feel like I haven't really sat down
and watched like a lot of Jet Li films.
- His stuff is actually
like really fucking good.
'Cause Donnie Yen hasn't...
Oh, another one, I think it's called,
it might be called "War" or
like "Warrior" or something.
It's like, it's about
like the three kingdoms
or something in China way back.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Ashley] "Warrior."
- What is it called?
- [Ashley] I think it's called "Warrior."
- Might be called just "Warrior."
- [Ashley] "Warrior," yeah.
- And it's such a good fucking-
- Jet Li film?
- Yeah, Jet Li's the main character.
And it's like this...
About how like a general
got like, I don't know,
I don't wanna spoil it.
But just watch it.
It's really fucking good.
Really, really fucking good.
- And I feel like, 'cause I,
I didn't want to put
another martial arts film
on my three by three,
but I feel like one of the
few things Southeast Asians
can be proud about are our
fucking martial arts films.
'Cause we have like,
"The Raid," "Ong-Bak."
- Yeah, "Ong-Bak" is really good.
- Pretty much the only
thing of Thai culture
that's ever been like popularized outside.
But yeah, like I, like,
I was really happy to see like the more
like gritty martial art films.
You know, you think of like, you know,
"Ip Man" is more like very clean.
- "The Raid" is really fucking good.
- "The Raid" is so good.
- Indonesian, right?
- Yeah, it's Indonesian.
- But directed by a Welsh guy.
- Oh really?
- It's a Welsh guy who directed it.
- Oh, shit.
- Is that "The Raid 1" or "Raid 2?"
'Cause I know he directed "Raid 2."
- "Raid..."
Who directed "Raid 1" and "2?"
Can you check real quick?
I swear, it's the same guy.
- That's another movie I've
heard of, but I've never seen.
- "The Raid?"
Dude!
"The Raid 1" is such a good premise.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Just get to the top of
an apartment building.
That's it.
- It's basically just a fighting game.
(Joey laughs)
- Like, Double Dragon.
- It's just Double Dragon.
- The fighting, like the
choreography is insane.
- [Ashley] Gareth Evans.
- Yeah, Gareth Evans.
The most Welsh name on earth.
Too Welsh names, Gareth and Evan.
- Fair enough.
- I just like, it's so bizarre.
There's a Welsh guy
directing an Indonesian film.
- [Joey] Hell yeah, dude.
- But it's just like awesome.
Like, it's such a good-
- That's some cross culture
pollination right there.
Hell yeah, dude.
- Look at us Thai and
Welsh here too, you know.
(everyone laughs)
But yeah, I mean, yeah,
I fucking love fighting,
martial arts movies.
I've watched nearly all of Jet Li's films.
I think I've watched most of them.
I couldn't watch some of the older ones
'cause they were
impossible to find online.
And I've watched I think all
of Donnie Yen's films pre "Ip Man."
I haven't watched "Ip Man 4."
I heard it was okay.
- I really liked "Ip Man 4."
- Really?
- Yeah, I actually it's my
second favorite "Ip Man."
- Maybe I'll watch it tonight.
- Because I feel like "Ip Man 4" is just-
- "3" was the worst.
- I feel like "Ip Man 4" was
just "Ip Man 2" done better.
Because my problem with "Ip
Man 2" is that the villain is
just so comical that I just
couldn't take him seriously.
It's just like, let's
characterize this character.
- So, the whole selling point
to like a Western audience
of "Ip Man" was just
that it's the guy who trained Bruce Lee.
That's literally the
selling point of that.
- [Joey] Fair enough.
- But he's supposed to be
like a master or something.
I don't know.
- I mean, that is a cool
like catch to be fair.
- I mean, that's how it was
marketed, and the story,
I don't, again, I don't
know how true it is,
but it's an interesting made
up story maybe if it is.
I don't know if it's true or not.
- [Ashley] It's true.
It's a real character but
the events are fictional.
- Yeah, that's normally how it goes
with martial arts people.
It's kind of hard to
survive some of the shit
they go through.
- Like, I'm sure they
fought all those people,
but they probably died halfway through.
- I mean, I don't think he
did fight 10 black belts.
You know, that's probably,
probably dramatized.
- Unless he's like a fucking super saiyan.
- There's another Donnie Yen film
that's actually really good
where he's like a detective
in a small town, I think in a village.
And it's really good
'cause it's like a mystery
of the martial arts
and it's just, yeah, it's really good.
I forgot what it's called.
Again, I've watched
these movies so long ago.
It came after "Ip Man."
- Same with Jackie Chan as well.
Some of his best works
are when he was young.
Like, fucking "Police Story."
- Oh, "Police Story" is fantastic.
- [Connor] Is that scene
where he jumps on the wire?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's completely real.
- [Ashley] Were you
thinking of "Flash Point?"
- Might be "Flash Point," yeah.
- [Ashley] Or "Kung Fu Jungle."
I think it's "Flash Point."
- Is it yellow the poster?
- [Ashley] The yellow one is, oh, oh wait.
We have the Chinese name.
It's the one where he's a teacher, right?
- Maybe.
Again, I might've
remembered it incorrectly
because it's been so-
- [Ashley] "Big Brother."
- I'll have to go back to
the thing and watch it.
I might be misremembering.
- I feel like one underrated
Donnie Yen film is
I think it was "SPX"
or something like that.
- What's the plot?
(Garnt sighs)
- Honestly, I do not remember.
But the only reason-
- "SPS" just sounds like a law firm.
- Let me, let me...
- Because what happened was,
is that you had Bruce Lee,
and then you had Jackie Chan.
And then when Jackie
Chan was getting older,
Jet Li was making films.
And then when Jet Li was getting
older, Donnie Yen came in.
But I don't really know who it is now.
Who's like the main martial arts guy.
- Martial arts guy?
- Who is the main like
face of martial arts now?
- [Ashley] Donnie Yen, but
he's close to retiring.
- I think it still is Donnie Yen
because he's in the new Marvel film.
- Yeah, but they also don't
really utilize him much.
- I mean, he's the villain, isn't it?
- I feel like martial
arts films are kind of
just like a little bit
of a dying breed almost
in like especially in the west I feel.
Like, I'm sure, like, you know,
if you go to Asia and
Southeast Asia they're still-
- I mean, the past 20 years
have all been from China.
Like, "Ip Man" is from China.
And then Donnie Yen is in
"Rogue One" from "Star Wars."
But again, when I was watching that movie
and you can see what Donnie Yen does,
kind of disappointed 'cause you're like,
Donnie Yen is so fucking
good, and they barely use him.
He just swings a fucking thing around.
It's like, oh cool.
- I haven't seen "Rogue One."
- [Ashley] It's cool, but
yeah, he could have done-
- He could have done so much.
Like anyone, like a lot
of people could have done
what Donnie Yen did in that film.
And I feel like why,
if you're getting Donnie Yen,
and he doesn't really
speak much in the film.
Because I don't think he
can speak much English.
- All I'm saying is there
hasn't been a "Rush Hour 2."
There hasn't been a modern "Rush Hour."
- Do a reboot with Donnie Yen.
- Yeah, honestly!
Fuck yeah.
- And Ice Cube.
- Ice Cube and Donnie Yen!
(everyone laughs)
The movie industry, we just
gave you a million dollar idea.
Donnie Yen and Ice Cube in "Rush Hour 7"
or whatever the next one is.
- [Ashley] The movie you were
thinking about was "SPL."
- "SPL."
- What's the plot of that movie?
Can you tell me the plot?
- [Ashley] "SPL?"
- Yeah.
- [Ashley] My phone's in Japanese.
- But I remember there's
one fight scene in "SPL"
which is like completely just improvised.
- Okay, is that in the street?
- Yeah, it's in the street.
And it's such a fucking good fight scene.
And then because the
whole premise around this,
the whole background
around this fight scene is
that they trained
together, these two actors,
Donnie Yen and I'm not sure
who the other person is,
but they trained together.
And because they were so familiar
with each other's fighting style,
they literally just improvise
this fight scene with just-
- That's so cool.
- With just this basic, okay,
here's what's meant to happen,
but let's just try to kill each other
and then let's just get it on film.
- It's so cool.
- It's such a good film as well.
- [Ashley] It's a story
where an honest detective
who's suffering from cancer
and about to retire resorts
to illegal means in order
to capture ruthless triads.
- Oh yeah.
- All I remember was there
was a police detective in it,
and I'm just like...
That's like, it's either like
traditional historical setting
or they're a police detective.
- Or it's a crime drama.
(everyone laughs)
Or it's like a neo noire crime drama.
But I mean like, oh God,
how do you like describe
this three by three?
It's like-
- How do you describe any?
- Powerful.
- How do describe any three by three?
- You can describe mine,
pretentious film critic.
- Pretentious, powerful.
- I don't know.
- Guilty pleasure.
(everyone laughs)
- I was trying to think of a word with P.
- P?
Why P?
- 'Cause-
- Pretentious, powerful.
Poopoo peepee.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, poopoo peepee.
- But yeah, I guess those
are our three by threes.
- Hope you get to watch
some interesting movies
if you haven't seen some of these.
- Yeah, please go and watch
all the movies we recommended.
- I have some movie recommendations
that I will be watching, I guess now.
- Yeah, I've honestly come out of this
with some movie recommendations.
And this was actually like-
- "Shrek 2."
- Obviously.
I always got time for "Shrek 2."
- We know what we're doing after this.
Sitting down with some "Shrek 2," baby.
- But no, I mean, like
it feels good to be able
to talk about movies
'cause I feel like I don't get
to talk about movies a lot,
even though like I kind of realized
whenever I talk about movies,
I've seen a lot of movies
and I feel like you guys have
seen a lot of movies as well.
And we even like off-camera,
we don't really talk
about movies in general.
- I think it just has to do with the fact
that we haven't really
had time to just sit down
and watch some.
- To be fair, I've not
watched movies in awhile.
- Yeah, me neither.
- I feel like, I don't know.
I feel like people don't
watch as many movies anymore.
- Yeah, like if it's not on Netflix,
then I probably haven't seen it.
- I'd say I've watched like
90% of the films I've seen
in like between the
ages of like 18 and 14.
- Yeah, I think that's usually
like the period in your life
when you're like, "I'm gonna
watch a lot of movies."
- It's also when I discovered you could
just Google the movies.
And I was like, holy shit.
- Yeah, I mean, my dad used to collect
like a shitload of DVDs when
BlockBuster was still a thing.
So, like I just watched a lot
of the movies with my dad.
- Yeah, I mean, I watch a lot less movies
than I did before as well
because now it's just all
been replaced by anime.
And a lot of anime movies.
- YouTube.
- And YouTube as well.
But I feel like if there's
a big enough movie,
then I probably have seen it.
Like, I'm surprised no one
put any Marvel movies here.
- Who the fuck cares?
- Who the fuck cares about Marvel?
- I mean, I care about Marvel.
I'm just like, Marvel's that one franchise
where I'm just like, hello, I'm a normie.
- Yeah, it's fun.
But it's not like, I'm never like,
"Fuck dude, that made me think something,
"that made me like happy."
- If I'm gonna watch a three hour-
- I don't know, I was
really fucking invested
in "Infinity War" and "Endgame."
I will say that.
- I didn't even watch those.
- "Endgame" was good.
But again, it wasn't like,
I thought it was amazing,
but it wasn't like,
when I left the cinema,
like a week later, I don't
think about "Endgame."
- Well, I'm surprised no
one put "John Wick" as well.
- I was close.
- I thought someone was
gonna put "John Wick" on.
- That was just another one of those
like it's fun, turn your brain off-
- No, no, no.
- It's amazing.
No!
- It's fucking amazing.
- No, I'm not saying it's a bad movie.
- "John Wick" is probably like
my favorite action series.
- It's like in the west,
they have "John Wick"
and in the east they have "Ip Man."
That's like, "Ip Man" is just
like the Asian equivalent
of "John Wick."
- Dude, man, I just...
It holds a very dear place in my heart.
I've watched all the "John
Wick" movies in the cinema.
And like I've watched the
last one that came out alone,
and the cinema was empty
and I had like such an
amazing time watching that.
It was like the last-
- Yeah!
- Bro, it was just fun.
I got to put my legs up on
the chair in front of me.
I had all my popcorn and I
just got to enjoy it, bro.
It was so good.
It was such a good,
dude, I'm so excited for the next one.
- I've only seen the
first "John Wick" movie.
- I'm so hype for it.
It gets better and better.
The second one's amazing.
- Again, it's another one of
those like long list of movies
that I hear people talking
about saying it's amazing.
And I'm like, all right, I'll watch it.
- I don't want to be too
normie, so I didn't put it on.
But it's, yeah.
- Yeah, just sometimes I
just don't know what movies
to watch because I,
like it's weird now 'cause
I don't know where to start
because you know, we're so
ingrained in like anime culture
that I know, you know, when
there's a hot anime coming out.
But in terms of movie recommendations,
anything from like the past five years,
if it's not been talked about a lot,
then I just probably haven't seen it.
- I mean, I barely have
enough time to watch anime
let alone fucking movies.
- Joey, you don't watch anime period.
- No, I don't.
I don't watch movies, period.
I don't watch anime, period.
That's just how it goes.
- Just read manga.
- I just read manga.
Just read manga and read porn.
- You know who does watch movies, Joey?
- Who?
- You tell me.
- Is it the patrons?
- It is the patrons.
- Hell yeah, bro.
Look at all these movie goers.
Let us know on the Reddit I guess.
I mean, I don't even have to
tell you guys to fucking do it
'cause you probably will
just fill up our subreddit
with your three by threes.
Please do so 'cause we
want to see what you guys-
- I think now that because we
have mods in the subreddit,
we're gonna have like a dedicated thread
for your movie three by threes.
And if you have any movie recommendations,
I'm actually all open ears for it.
- Oh, absolutely.
- To me watching movies is my downtime
because I just, I can watch it
and I don't have to think
about making a video on it.
I can just watch it to enjoy it.
- Exactly.
- It's just like,
to me with movies is how I
feel other people are to anime
where I'm just looking
for some good movies.
So, any movies that have come out recently
that you might recommend.
- Yeah, if you have any recommendations,
please leave it down in the comments.
- I've been pretty out of
touch with the movie scene.
- Tell us, gamers.
Tell us your favorite movies.
- Yeah, tell us down
in the comments below.
Also, if you like the show,
then consider supporting
us on our Patreon,
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter.
Give us your three by
threes on the subreddit.
And if you hate our faces,
listen to us on Spotify.
But yeah, hopefully you guys
enjoyed this themed episode.
There's gonna be more
three by threes coming.
I'm just gonna say that right now.
- There's gonna be a lot
more three by threes coming.
more three by threes coming,
so if you like this kind of episode,
then stick around for more.
- I mean, it's just an
easy format, isn't it?
- Yeah, it really is.
- Until next time.
Bye!
- Bye!
(chill music plays)